Hey guys, it's 2025, okay? It's 2025. What are your dreams for this year? Um, that I may- God, I don't know what kind of tone to take with the coffee chat because like what if it's like, you know... You can go balls out literally. Really? I can start cursing right now? Yeah.
嘿伙计们，2025年了，好吗？是2025年了。你们今年有什么梦想？嗯，我可能——天哪，我不知道该用什么语气来聊咖啡，因为万一……你可以彻底放开，真的。真的吗？我现在可以开始骂人了吗？可以。
Saying bad words. By the way, the shorts I'm wearing, I could go balls out real easy. Wait, Will, stop it. You don't know this person yet. Oh, you just set the balls out of your. No! Oh!
说脏话。顺便说一下，我穿的这条短裤，我很容易就能彻底放开。等等，威尔，停下。你还不认识这个人。哦，你刚才把你的……不！哦！
Don't show us your balls. I'm not going to. How dare you? All right, now listen. Oh, now listen. Now listen. Hang on a second. No, no, no, first of all, don't go to your script.
别给我们看你的下体。我不会的。你怎么敢？好了，现在听着。哦，现在听着。现在听着。等一下。不，不，不，首先，别看你的剧本。
What are you talking about? I have. You've been working on this. I saw your eyes go to your script. Let me see your material. No, now here's my thing. No, I was gonna say that Jason missed Willie's birthday last week, we missed you.
你在说什么？我有。你一直在准备这个。我看到你的眼睛看向你的剧本了。让我看看你的材料。不，现在这是我的事。不，我本来想说杰森上周错过了威利的生日，我们想你了。
Yeah, thanks man. How'd that go? But listen to this, I told Will, I was gonna say this on the show to you, Jay. You can never make fun of me for, well you can, for my eating habits and my diet. This fella right here at his own birthday dinner. He's a real shit pig.
是啊，谢了伙计。那次聚会怎么样？但听着，我告诉威尔，我会在节目里对你说这件事，杰。你永远不能拿我的饮食习惯和节食开玩笑，好吧，你可以拿这个开玩笑。这家伙在他自己的生日晚宴上。他真是个贪吃鬼。
Brought, but Jay, he brought his own Hershey's caramel syrup. First of all. In his pocket, in his pocket, by the way. And then I asked if I could have it. You dropped some nice weight for this film. You're gonna be 420 in a week. No, no, no, no, I'm still on one cheat meal a week. By the way, I didn't bring it in my pocket.
带了，但是杰，他带了他自己的好时焦糖糖浆。首先。顺便说一下，在他的口袋里，在他的口袋里。然后我问我能不能吃点。你为了这部电影减了不少体重。你一周后就要420磅了。不，不，不，不，我还在坚持每周一次欺骗餐。顺便说一下，我没把它放在口袋里。
I made Archie, my 16-year-old, put it in his pocket. Bring it, he muled it. I had too much shame, he muled it in for me. Then Kimmel said, is that your tanning lotion? And then, by the way, so everybody made fun, at which point they bring Sundays out for everybody, and every person asked for it. Yeah, that's a good call.
我让我16岁的儿子阿奇把它放在他的口袋里。带上它，他像走私一样带进来的。我太不好意思了，他帮我走私进来的。然后坎摩尔说，那是你的美黑乳液吗？然后，顺便说一下，大家都在取笑，这时他们给每个人端上了圣代，每个人都想要一份。是啊，那是个好主意。
It was amazing. Everybody had individual Hot Fudge Sundays brought to them. Well, it's like when you drive past a car crash, you're going to look, you know, but you don't want to. I guess so. It's human nature. But it was just so rich watching people making jokes. Look at you with your camera, get it over here, okay?
太棒了。每个人都得到了单独的热软糖圣代。嗯，就像你开车经过车祸现场，你会想看，你知道，但你不想看。我想是吧。这是人性。但看着人们开玩笑真是太有意思了。看看你拿着摄像机，把它拿过来，好吗？
Yeah. And then I tried to, you know, cause I missed it so then the next day I texted Willie on the day of the first Maple Leafs game on the next round. And I said, hey, I feel bad, I'm gonna fly into town and I'd love to see you. I'm gonna pick you up at five.
是啊。然后我试着，你知道，因为我错过了，所以第二天，在下一轮枫叶队第一场比赛那天，我给威利发了短信。我说，嘿，我觉得很抱歉，我要飞到城里来，我很想见你。我五点去接你。
Now five o'clock was when the puck dropped. He didn't, he's so, I know he didn't know what I was, what the joke was there. He was just like, oh, you did or you didn't? Of course I knew what the joke was. Really, because I did it on game two and you still didn't get it. I don't get what the joke is.
五点钟正好是比赛开始的时候。他没有，他太……我知道他不知道那里的笑话是什么。他只是说，哦，你做了还是没做？我当然知道笑话是什么。真的吗，因为我在第二场比赛时也这么做了，你还是没明白。我不明白笑话是什么。
The joke is like, you must not be busy. Yeah, I need to see you right at the point that the puck drops. Oh, I see, I see, got it. Yeah, can't be talked to. Yeah, no, I did. And, but anyway, yeah, the Leafs, who knows what's gonna happen when they go forward in this
笑话是，你一定不忙。是啊，我需要在比赛开始的时候见到你。哦，我明白了，我明白了，懂了。是啊，不能被打扰。是啊，不，我做了。但不管怎样，是啊，枫叶队，谁知道他们接下来会发生什么
because this will be way later. Oh yeah, but we've got a real series now. We've got a real series. I was in Toronto this weekend, I did my hospital gig for the Michael Garan Hospital. We raised millions of dollars for the hospital, which is amazing. That's so great. We love, this is the hospital I like to be in.
因为这会是很久以后的事了。哦，是的，但我们现在有真正的系列赛了。我们有真正的系列赛。我这个周末在多伦多，我为迈克尔·加伦医院做了医院演出。我们为医院筹集了数百万美元，这太棒了。太好了。我们喜欢，这是我喜欢待的医院。
Do you still take lira? Do you still take lira? Michael Garren Hospital, we take lira. That's really funny. I have 600,000 lira here, two dollars. Remember, it used to be like 100,000 lira for two dollars. Yeah, I know, there's nowhere else to go and you can get like $100. So that's unfortunate that it didn't time out with the Leafs being in Toronto, right?
你们还收里拉吗？你们还收里拉吗？迈克尔·加伦医院，我们收里拉。那真好笑。我这有60万里拉，两美元。记得吗，以前10万里拉才值两美元。是啊，我知道，没别的地方可去，你可以换到100美元左右。所以枫叶队在多伦多时没赶上时间真是太遗憾了，对吧？
They were playing down in Florida. They were playing in Florida, but I watched with the whole family, my dad and my sisters and everybody, we went to our pub, The Queen and Beaver, which is James and Kerr, which I'm also a part of. That's a rough title. The Queen and Beaver, it's pretty good.
他们在佛罗里达打比赛。他们在佛罗里达打比赛，但我全家，我爸爸、我姐妹们和大家一起看了比赛，我们去了我们的酒吧，The Queen and Beaver，这也是詹姆斯和克尔开的，我也是合伙人。那名字真粗俗。The Queen and Beaver，挺好的。
The Queen and Beaver, yeah. And it's a great pub if you're in Toronto. You ever sub out that N for an S? Queens? Queens? Queens Beaver? Oh, the Queens. Oh, oh, oh. Add an S, not take an N out.
The Queen and Beaver，是啊。如果你在多伦多，那是个很棒的酒吧。你有没有把那个N换成S？Queens？Queens？Queens Beaver？哦，Queens。哦，哦，哦。加个S，不是去掉N。
Oh, you take a Queen and Beaver. Queen and Beaver. Queen apostrophe N Beaver. You take out the apostrophe N, you put in apostrophe S, the Queen's beef. Well, here's, first of all, it's and, it's not the. I'll meet you at the Queen's beef. It's not Queen's beef.
哦，你拿走Queen and Beaver。Queen and Beaver。Queen撇号N Beaver。你去掉撇号N，换成撇号S，Queen's beef。好吧，首先，是and，不是the。我在Queen's beef见你。不是Queen's beef。
I had the greatest meal at the Queen's beef. God, what did you do? Wait, that's the joke. The joke is. It's kind of salty there at the Queen's beef. Wow. Guys, my guest today is a father of six. He's deeply offended.
我在Queen's beef吃了顿最棒的饭。天哪，你做了什么？等等，这就是笑话。笑话是。Queen's beef那里有点咸。哇。伙计们，我今天的嘉宾是六个孩子的父亲。他深受冒犯。
No, he won't be. He's a father of six, former soccer hopeful, football. His resume includes washing dishes in an Indian restaurant and once cooking lunch for Princess Diana. These days he's got a soft spot for In-N-Out burgers. I just had two yesterday, which is a true story. Two, you needed two? I did, I got two, I ate them in in my car let me check out the believability scale
不，他不会的。他是六个孩子的父亲，曾经的足球希望之星，橄榄球。他的简历包括在印度餐馆洗碗，还曾为戴安娜王妃做过午餐。这些天他特别喜欢In-N-Out汉堡。我昨天刚吃了两个，这是真实故事。两个，你需要两个？是的，我买了两个，我在车里吃了它们，让我检查一下那个可信度量表
on that by the way and some of the beef fell in between my seats and I had to get it out because I knew it would smell if you had to suck it out I did with my straw first time you suck beef out of seats sorry gang at the Queen's Beef. At the Queen's Beef. That's a different one. The Queen's Beef is next door. We went for dessert at the Peach Crease afterwards. Guys, we're losing listener by the moment. I know, sorry. He has an obsession with cold plunges, Will.
顺便说一下，有些牛肉掉在我的座位缝里了，我不得不把它弄出来，因为我知道如果不弄出来会发臭，如果你不得不把它吸出来的话。我确实用吸管吸出来了，第一次从座位里吸出牛肉，抱歉各位，在Queen's Beef。在Queen's Beef。那是另一家。我们之后去Peach Crease吃了甜点。伙计们，我们正在失去听众。我知道，抱歉。他对冷水浴有执念，威尔。
You love that. And a few Michelin stars under his belt, all while turning, swearing into a love language. Today he's bringing the fire in and out of the kitchen. It's the wonderful and delicious Gordon Ramsay, who I've loved forever. Guys, just met him a couple weeks ago with you, Willie. Wait, what? We just ran into you, Gordon.
你喜欢那个。他名下还有几颗米其林星，同时把咒骂变成了爱的语言。今天他要把火带进厨房，也要带出厨房。他就是美妙而美味的戈登·拉姆齐，我一直都很喜欢他。伙计们，几周前刚和你们见过他，威利。等等，什么？我们刚碰到你，戈登。
What are you talking about, where? Yeah, over at our friend Bradley's place. Yeah, that's right. Oh, I didn't know that. Now, how do you all know each other, Willie? How did that all, that wasn't the first time you met him? No, we met through our friend Bradley's place. Yeah, that's right. Oh, I didn't know that. Now, how do you all know each other, Willie? How did that all, that wasn't the first time you met him. No, we met through our friend. Gordon, we're going to let you speak in a moment.
你在说什么，在哪里？是啊，在我们朋友布拉德利的住处。是啊，没错。哦，我不知道。那么，你们大家是怎么认识的，威利？那是你们第一次见他吗？不，我们是通过我们的朋友布拉德利的住处认识的。是啊，没错。哦，我不知道。那么，你们大家是怎么认识的，威利？那是你们第一次见他吗。不，我们是通过我们的朋友认识的。戈登，我们一会儿让你说话。
Rob Wade, right, Gordon? Gordon, we had dinner with our friend Rob Wade. That's right. Guys, good to see you all, and thank you. Great to see you. Wait, this is amazing. I've never met you, Gordon, and I'm a huge fan. And meanwhile, I didn't know you knew these two guys.
罗伯·韦德，对吧，戈登？戈登，我们和我们的朋友罗伯·韦德一起吃了晚饭。没错。伙计们，很高兴见到你们，谢谢。很高兴见到你们。等等，这太神奇了。我从没见过你，戈登，我是你的超级粉丝。同时，我不知道你认识这两个家伙。
Yeah, catch up, Sean. I'm here, that's why I can't wait. Gordon, this, and I'm a huge fan. And meanwhile, I didn't know you knew these two guys. Yeah, catch up, Sean. I'm here, that's why I can't wait. Gordon, this is what I want to know. Thank you so much for being here. You're such a good dude. Where are we finding you right now? Because you're always, every time I see you, you're always coming from the airport
是啊，跟上节奏，肖恩。我在这儿，所以我等不及了。戈登，这个，我是你的超级粉丝。同时，我不知道你认识这两个家伙。是啊，跟上节奏，肖恩。我在这儿，所以我等不及了。戈登，这是我想知道的。非常感谢你能来。你真是个好人。我们现在在哪儿能找到你？因为你总是，每次我见到你，你总是从机场来
or going to the airport. No, we've got the up-fronts today, so in New York. Oh, people still have those, even though the network television business is kind of. Fuck me, yes, unfortunately. They do, they do, and they're painful. Oh my God. The first one I ever went to, so for Tracy,
或者去机场。不，我们今天有预展，在纽约。哦，人们还有那个吗，尽管电视网络业务有点……去他的，是的，不幸的是。他们有，他们有，而且很痛苦。天哪。我参加的第一个，所以对特雷西来说，
the up-fronts are where networks put up their shows, they display kind of what the fall season's going to be and the ad agencies are going to commit to ad dollars. They pre-sell all the commercials. Right. And now streamers are doing it too. I'm on my way there for Netflix. Oh wow.
预展是电视网展示他们节目、展示秋季档内容以及广告代理商承诺广告费的地方。他们预售所有的广告。对。现在流媒体也在做。我正要去参加Netflix的预展。哦，哇。
So the first time I went to Gordon was. See you there, Gordon. The first time I went to an upfront, I was like, can't we handle this into a fax machine? Like, can't we just send an email saying like what the shows are? And why do you have to like the dog and the pony of it? And how were the laughs to that joke? Can we handle this into a fax machine? Like, can't we just send an email saying what the shows are? Why do you have to like the dog and the pony of it, right?
所以我第一次去戈登那里是。在那儿见，戈登。我第一次去参加预展时，我想，我们不能把它传真过去吗？我们不能只发封邮件说节目是什么吗？为什么一定要搞这种排场？那个笑话反响如何？我们不能把它传真过去吗？我们不能只发封邮件说节目是什么吗？为什么一定要搞这种排场，对吧？
And how are the laughs to that joke? Hey, listen. No, it wasn't a joke. I was serious. Like, can't we just, why are we on it? First of all, Gordon is keeping, single-handedly keeping Fox on the air. I know, that isn't true.
那个笑话反响如何？嘿，听着。不，那不是个笑话。我是认真的。为什么我们要在这儿？首先，戈登凭一己之力让福克斯电视台维持播出。我知道，那不是真的。
That needs to be said. That needs to be said. 20 years. 20 years. 20 years in 2004 we came over. As you know, there was not many mainstream foodie programs on the network. And how many shows in 20 years? I think we've, is it 10, 11 or 12?
这需要说出来。这需要说出来。20年了。20年了。2004年我们过来的时候。如你所知，电视网上没有多少主流美食节目。20年里有多少节目？我想我们有，是10个、11个还是12个？
Wow, that's unbelievable. It's unbelievable. Good Lord. It's really impressive. I've watched every single episode of Kitchen Nightmares. Stop it. I love it. Stop it. For real, I really have.
哇，那太不可思议了。太不可思议了。天哪。真的很令人印象深刻。我看过《厨房噩梦》的每一集。别说了。我喜欢它。别说了。真的，我真的看过。
He's obsessed. I love it so much. Has there ever been a celebrity edition? Could Sean be on a celebrity edition? How do I get yelled at? Please don't open a restaurant, Sean. Please, please, please don't. I got a good name for it.
他着迷了。我太喜欢了。有没有过名人版？肖恩能上名人版吗？我怎么才能被骂？请不要开餐馆，肖恩。求求你，求求你，千万别开。我有个好名字。
The Queen's Beef. The Queen's Beef, Jesus Christ. That's the problem. That's the one big problem in this industry that anybody can open a restaurant. It's not like an actor, it's not like a doctor or a lawyer, a bar school. I go back to that dinner party when they say,
The Queen's Beef。The Queen's Beef，天哪。这就是问题所在。这个行业最大的问题就是任何人都能开餐馆。不像演员，不像医生或律师，需要考证。我回到那个晚宴，当他们说，
hey, Sean, your food's fucking delicious, man. You should open a restaurant. So the next day, you start looking at taking leases out in the neighborhood for these incredible little bistros. And then that reality turns into a nightmare because they sort of, they don't fully understand that it's a business. neighborhood for these incredible little bistros. And then that reality turns into a nightmare because they don't fully understand that it's a business. Like I'm just going to cook for my friends and other people will like it too. And pardon the pun here, but have you cracked what maybe the secret sauce is to keeping a restaurant open?
嘿，肖恩，你的食物太好吃了，伙计。你应该开家餐馆。所以第二天，你就开始在附近寻找这些不可思议的小酒馆的租约。然后那个现实变成了噩梦，因为他们有点，他们不完全明白这是一种生意。附近寻找这些不可思议的小酒馆。然后那个现实变成了噩梦，因为他们不完全明白这是一种生意。就像我只是要为我的朋友做饭，其他人也会喜欢。请原谅我用双关语，但你破解了保持餐馆营业的秘方了吗？
Because I would imagine when it first opens you need sort of to be somewhat of a popular restaurateur where you've got a certain client base that they're going to come in and they're going to populate it for the first week, month, whatever. And then of course the food's got to be good and that can carry you for another couple of months. But how do you get into years after years after years? How do you keep it hot and fresh?
因为我想象当它刚开业时，你需要成为一个受欢迎的餐馆老板，拥有一批固定的客户群，他们会进来，在第一周、一个月或无论多久内填满它。然后当然食物必须好吃，这可以支撑你再过几个月。但你是怎么做到年复一年地经营下去的？你是怎么保持它的热度和新鲜感的？
Yeah, great question. First of all, you need to keep it local, right? The secret of any great restaurant is filling it Monday to Wednesday. Thursday, Friday, you need to keep it local, right? The secret of any great restaurant is filling it Monday to Wednesday. Thursday, Friday, Saturday, it takes care of itself. And so that's the essence of getting it right. Filling it Monday, Tuesday, and Wednesday nights. Especially in the middle of November and early into January.
是啊，好问题。首先，你需要保持本地化，对吧？任何伟大餐馆的秘诀就是填满周一到周三。周四、周五，你需要保持本地化，对吧？任何伟大餐馆的秘诀就是填满周一到周三。周四、周五、周六，它自己就会好起来。所以这就是做对事情的本质。填满周一、周二和周三晚上。特别是在11月中旬和1月初。
So stay local, okay? Keep the produce simple, don't overcomplicate things. And don't go crazy on the prices. Because it's a lot easier to make money on alcohol than it is on food. overcomplicate things. And you've just got to know your market. You've got to really know the market. And you've got to know how to, you know, so we all jokes aside, so the Queen and Beaver is a gastropub in Toronto that my friend, James and Curve started and he was a restaurateur.
所以保持本地化，好吗？保持食材简单，不要把事情搞得太复杂。不要在价格上发疯。因为靠酒精赚钱比靠食物赚钱容易得多。把事情搞得太复杂。你只需要了解你的市场。你必须真正了解市场。你必须知道如何，你知道，所以我们撇开玩笑不谈，Queen and Beaver是多伦多的一家美食酒吧，我朋友詹姆斯和克尔开的，他是个餐馆老板。
So he had another restaurant and then he opened a few and including the Queen and Beaver and the Oxley. Now he runs exclusively Queen and Beaver and I have a small interest in it and have since the beginning. Oh, say it one more time then. But that is his business and that's what he does, right? That's his full-time thing and he runs a business
所以他有另一家餐馆，然后他开了几家，包括Queen and Beaver和The Oxley。现在他专门经营Queen and Beaver，我有一小部分股份，从一开始就有。哦，再说一遍。但那是他的生意，那是他做的事，对吧？那是他的全职工作，他经营着生意
and we're in the penny business. So we have to count everything and everything matters and everything is locally, we make everything in the restaurant, all the bread is made in the restaurant, it's well-priced and the menu's very good and it's very simple. Again, it's just a gastropub, Queen and Beaver,
我们做的是小本生意。所以我们必须计算一切，一切都很重要，一切都是本地的，我们在餐馆里制作一切，所有的面包都是在餐馆里做的，价格合理，菜单非常好，而且非常简单。再说一次，它只是一个美食酒吧，Queen and Beaver，
just above Dundas, open seven days a week. But that's the thing, but like Jason was saying, after all those years of, like, cause I go to this restaurant, we all have our favorite restaurants. One of mine ends in, well, Jason's like, it's McDonald's. No, it's, I love Chin Chin, but no. And after years and years, how do you find the energy
就在邓达斯街上面，一周七天营业。但这就是重点，就像杰森说的，在经历了那么多年之后，因为我去这家餐馆，我们都有我们最喜欢的餐馆。我的一家以，好吧，杰森说是麦当劳。不，我喜欢Chin Chin，但不是。在多年之后，你是怎么找到精力和
and the passion to maintain and sustain that restaurant? Yeah, I think it's important to change the staff every three to four years, so that I get complacent and lazy. I've been a great motivator of planning succession as well. This industry is an absolute bitch, and it's notorious for the burnout. And so when I start to spot that in the team, it's time to take a bit of a sabbatical and move them on.
激情来维持和支撑那家餐馆的？是啊，我认为每三到四年更换员工很重要，这样我就不会自满和懒惰。我也一直是一个很好的继任计划推动者。这个行业简直是个婊子，而且以职业倦怠著称。所以当我开始在团队中发现这一点时，是时候休个假，让他们离开了。
Restaurant Gordon Ramsay this year celebrates 28 years and 25 years at Three Star Michelin. So that's... Wow, wow, that's amazing. That's in Chelsea, a tiny little restaurant. What's it called, say it again? Restaurant Gordon Ramsay. So I decided-
戈登·拉姆齐餐馆今年庆祝28周年，并保持米其林三星25年。所以那是……哇，哇，太棒了。那是在切尔西，一家很小的餐馆。叫什么名字，再说一遍？戈登·拉姆齐餐馆。所以我决定——
Oh, restaurant Gordon Ramsay. After getting screwed over by so many partners at the age of 30 when I convinced my wife to sort of sell any form of asset we had in order to conjure up some form of deposit to get my own restaurant. Yeah, back in 1998, yeah. Wow, that's impressive. What type of stuff do you guys serve there?
哦，戈登·拉姆齐餐馆。在30岁时被这么多合伙人坑过之后，我劝说我妻子卖掉我们所有的资产，以便凑出某种押金来开我自己的餐馆。是啊，回到1998年，是啊。哇，那令人印象深刻。你们那里供应什么类型的食物？
So, highly seasonal. Again, it moves from going into summer now, coming out of spring. It functions five days a week. It's one brigade. We're closed Sunday, Monday. And so it's sort of one team, one dream. And that's how you conceptualize something that can run for decades, because you keep it small and powerful. Right, I love that. And for a dummy like me, a Michelin star obviously is sort of like the, you know, gold medal of a restaurant. And one is great, two is better, three is the best.
所以，高度季节性。同样，现在进入夏天，走出春天。它每周营业五天。这是一个团队。我们周日、周一休息。所以这是一种团队，一个梦想。这就是你构思可以运行几十年的东西的方式，因为你保持它小而强大。对，我喜欢这个。对于像我这样的笨蛋来说，米其林星显然就像是餐馆的金牌。一颗很好，两颗更好，三颗最好。
14, you've had 14, is that right? Yeah, we've won, yeah, over the years. We've got currently just under 10, but three stars is the ultimate. We've got currently just under 10, but three stars is the ultimate. And it's not just about the pompous wine cellar and the thick linen and, yeah. It's about the food being consistent
14颗，你有过14颗，对吗？是啊，我们赢过，是啊，这些年来。我们目前有不到10颗，但三星是终极目标。我们目前有不到10颗，但三星是终极目标。这不仅仅是关于浮夸的酒窖和厚实的亚麻布，是的。这是关于食物的一致性
and the food being immaculate. And it's not easy to get as Gordon, what he's not, what he's leading out is, it's so hard to get just one, let alone two, let alone three, let alone three. It's the most difficult thing to do. But like there are, I'm slightly smarter for some reason about hotel stars, like there are certain things
以及食物的完美无瑕。这不容易得到，戈登，他没说的是，这太难得到了，只得到一颗，更不用说两颗，更不用说三颗，更不用说三颗。这是最难做到的事情。但就像有，我出于某种原因对酒店星级稍微聪明一点，就像有某些事情
a hotel has to do in order to qualify for four stars versus three, five stars versus four. What is it that gets you a star? What is it that gets you two? What does that get you? Three. Sure. So the first star is based on consistency and good food.
酒店必须做才能获得四星而不是三星，五星而不是四星。是什么让你获得一颗星？是什么让你获得两颗？是什么让你获得三颗？当然。所以第一颗星是基于一致性和好的食物。
The second star is a level of excellence that is very rarely found, again, with great service. And third star is, you know, it's utter perfection. But perfection every day. Not just when the head chef's there, it's on a daily basis, lunch and dinner. So go back to Russian Gordon Ramsay, we've only got 10 tables.
第二颗星是一种非常罕见的卓越水平，同样，伴随着优质的服务。第三颗星是，你知道，它是彻底的完美。但每天都要完美。不仅仅是主厨在的时候，而是每天，午餐和晚餐。所以回到戈登·拉姆齐餐馆，我们只有10张桌子。
So everyone says, how do you maintain that? Because we cook 40 lunch and 40 dinners, 80 guests a day, but we're on what, 64 staff? You know, in that entire place. So you look at the restaurant. Yeah, but then you got your lease, and you got to pay overhead. And then how does it, so is it like a team
所以每个人都说，你是怎么维持的？因为我们每天做40份午餐和40份晚餐，80位客人，但我们有64名员工？你知道，在那个整个地方。所以你看看那家餐馆。是啊，但你还有租约，你必须支付管理费用。然后它是怎么，所以它就像一个团队
of these Michelin folks that kind of go around the world, they don't let you know that they're coming, I would assume, and they just kind of pop in every once in a while, and then like Ratatouille, like the Pixar movies. That's exactly that, I mean, they're all incognito, you never get to see or hear them. Maybe they'll introduce themselves once a year. And you know, they suspect.
这些米其林的人，他们环游世界，我假设他们不会让你知道他们要来，他们只是偶尔顺便过来，然后就像《料理鼠王》，就像皮克斯电影。正是那样，我的意思是，他们都是隐姓埋名的，你永远看不到或听不到他们。也许他们一年会自我介绍一次。你知道，他们怀疑。
It's nice to meet you, Goddard, and I will give you one star maybe. They don't, they say nothing. They just pay the bill. Can I have a quick word with the chef? How's it going? And they keep it very, very minimal. You know that.
很高兴见到你，戈达德，我可能会给你一颗星。他们什么都不说。他们只是付账。我能和厨师说两句吗？怎么样？他们保持得非常非常低调。你知道的。
Except for the big fat tire guy. Except for the big fat tire guy. He's hard to miss. He's the fat fucker that ate everything. By the way, you know, it is Michelin tires, right? As you know, Gordon will tell you. Oh, it's the to miss. He's the fat fuck that ate everything. By the way, it is Michelin tires, right? As you know, Gordon will tell you. Oh, it's the same company? So Gordon, will you tell the story of how they originated, right?
除了那个大胖轮胎人。除了那个大胖轮胎人。他很难被错过。他就是那个吃掉一切的胖混蛋。顺便说一下，你知道，那是米其林轮胎，对吧？如你所知，戈登会告诉你。哦，很难错过。他就是那个吃掉一切的胖混蛋。顺便说一下，那是米其林轮胎，对吧？如你所知，戈登会告诉你。哦，是同一家公司？那么戈登，你会讲讲它们是怎么起源的吗，对吧？
I would like to know. Yeah. And by the way, Gordon, before you get... You've had 17 Michelin stars. Thank you. 17. So Gordon, tell them how it started. So it's in the southwest of France,
我想知道。是啊。顺便说一下，戈登，在你开始之前……你获得过17颗米其林星。谢谢。17颗。所以戈登，告诉他们它是怎么开始的。所以它在法国西南部，
and this company, as you know, was formidable for tires. And so they came up with the idea back in 1900 to sort of formulate this guide. So as you travel across France, you sort of stop off and you pick up and you sleep in these little hotels and they start sort of sprinkling stars over them. But it's the longest serving guide in the world. It's one of the most prestigious and it's a guide that you never get to know. So...
这家公司，如你所知，在轮胎方面非常强大。所以他们在1900年想出了这个主意，制定了这个指南。所以当你穿越法国时，你会停下来，在这些小旅馆里睡觉，他们开始在上面撒上星星。但这是世界上服务时间最长的指南。它是最负盛名的指南之一，而且是一个你永远无法了解的指南。所以……
Isn't that amazing? Yeah, that is. So it started... I've only been once. I've been to one three-star Michelin restaurant and that was in Tokyo. I went to Giro. And...
那不是很神奇吗？是啊，确实。所以它开始……我只去过一次。我去过一家米其林三星餐馆，那是在东京。我去了次郎的店。而且……
Beautiful. Yeah, beautiful. And he made me my dinner in front of me, Giro. Wow. Yeah, the old boy. This was in 2015. That's incredible, the documentary's amazing. Amazing documentary. He's got the sons there,
漂亮。是啊，漂亮。他在我面前为我做了晚餐，次郎。哇。是啊，老人家。这是在2015年。那太不可思议了，纪录片太棒了。很棒的纪录片。他有儿子在那里，
but he won't hand it over to his sons because they don't think they're sort of competent enough. Have you boys, Sean and Jason, have you seen that documentary, Giro, Dreams of Sushi? No, I wonder what's it called? Giro, Dreams of Sushi, J-I-R-O. And he is an apprentice who's making that one special dish
但他不会把它交给他的儿子，因为他们认为他们不够胜任。你们两个，肖恩和杰森，看过那部纪录片《次郎梦寿司》吗？不，我想知道它叫什么？《次郎梦寿司》，J-I-R-O。他有一个学徒正在制作那道特别的菜
that I think is a sort of a cake type thing. And he doesn't let him make it to serve. He has to be an apprentice and practice for 10. Five years. Five or 10 years. Five years to wash the rice and then 10 years to sort of get up to speed. It's insane.
我想那是一种蛋糕之类的东西。他不让他做来供应。他必须当学徒并练习10年。五年。五年或10年。五年洗米，然后10年赶上进度。太疯狂了。
No way. Yes, it's crazy. And that's the sort of level of perfection that it takes to become a three-star Michelin, three-star. Well, you have to really want to do it, yeah. But I'll be honest, once you get there, you've got to delegate, you've got to get it off your radar in a way that you bring the next tier of talent through.
不可能。是的，太疯狂了。这就是成为米其林三星所需要的完美水平。好吧，你必须真的想做，是啊。但我会诚实地说，一旦你到了那里，你必须授权，你必须以一种方式把它从你的雷达上移开，让你培养下一层人才。
Otherwise, you're going to get changed at that stove. Yeah, I want to get into like, where did you find, like who was your inspiration to be fearless? Because you're the, I mean, you're fearless in business, in your restaurants, be fearless. Because you're the, I mean, you're fearless in business, in your restaurants, in life. I mean, you just go and go and go and you attack life. It's crazy. Yeah, I think, I'll be honest,
否则，你会被锁在那个炉子旁。是啊，我想进入，比如，你在哪里找到，比如谁是你的灵感来源，让你变得无畏？因为你是，我的意思是，你在商业上、在你的餐馆里是无畏的，变得无畏。因为你是，我的意思是，你在商业上、在你的餐馆里、在生活中是无畏的。我的意思是，你只是不断前进，不断前进，你攻击生活。太疯狂了。是啊，我想，我会诚实地说，
I think that's growing up in poverty. In a way that, you know, coming from a counselor state, sort of deprived area, going to school with like holes in your trousers and your mum having to put leather patches on your knees, which then actually turned out quite cool. Getting called out by your mates because you're having to line up in the queue for dinner tickets because you didn't have the money to buy food. Mom and Dad, we never bought individual photos.
我想那是成长在贫困中。以一种，你知道，来自一个贫民区，那种贫困地区，穿着裤子上有洞的衣服去上学，你妈妈不得不给你的膝盖打上皮补丁，结果反而变得很酷。因为你不得不排队领晚餐券而被朋友嘲笑，因为你没有钱买食物。妈妈和爸爸，我们从不买个人照片。
So we had to go for that family shot that all three of us together, that the school were paying for. So you were pulled out of class on the last day of those shots and made to feel so bad because they knew you weren't doing individual shots. And then you all got called out in the middle of the lesson. When did you know, when did you know, so growing up in that, when did you know that like, I'm going to make it out of here, I'm smart enough, I have the brain to get me out of my situation? Yeah, from that moment, yeah. Yeah, first off, as you know, I started in soccer,
所以我们不得不去拍那张我们三个在一起的全家福，学校付钱的那种。所以你在那些照片的最后一天被叫出教室，让你感觉很糟糕，因为他们知道你没拍个人照。然后你们都在课间被叫出来。你什么时候知道，你什么时候知道，成长在那种环境中，你什么时候知道，比如，我要从这里走出去，我足够聪明，我有大脑让我摆脱我的处境？是啊，从那一刻起，是啊。是啊，首先，如你所知，我开始踢足球，
so I had a really strong sporting background. At the age of 18, I got released from Glasgow Rangers in a way that I was in their academy. You played under 14 football, right? Yeah, under 14, under 16, under 18. Because I was so big and sort of lanky and fast, I sort of played two years above my station. So I was playing in a game, it was a friendly game,
所以我有一个非常强大的体育背景。18岁时，我被格拉斯哥流浪者队解雇了，因为我在他们的青训学院。你踢过14岁以下足球，对吧？是啊，14岁以下，16岁以下，18岁以下。因为我长得很高，而且又瘦又快，我踢的位置比我的年龄高两岁。所以我当时在踢一场比赛，那是一场友谊赛，
pre-season friendly game, and I got involved in a horrific tackle, pre-season friendly game, I got let go, they told me they'd keep an eye on me, and all that bullshit that comes with a sorry goodbye. And then I got into a catering course, just a basic college course where I'd spend two days a week at college and five days a week in a local hotel. And that's how it started. And so football, but initially football really saved you,
季前友谊赛，我卷入了一次可怕的铲球，季前友谊赛，我被解雇了，他们告诉我他们会留意我，所有那些随之而来的抱歉和再见。然后我参加了一个餐饮课程，只是一个基础的大学课程，我每周在大学待两天，在当地一家酒店待五天。这就是它开始的方式。所以足球，但最初足球真的救了你，
would you say, from your situation early on? Yeah, I mean, yeah, exactly that. Because it sort of not just kept me out of trouble, but it got me into a level of discipline that I enjoyed. But most importantly, I excelled. You know, I really did. Yeah. We'll be right back.
你会说，从你早期的处境中？是啊，我的意思是，是啊，正是那样。因为它不仅让我远离麻烦，而且让我进入了一种我喜欢的纪律水平。但最重要的是，我表现出色。你知道，我真的做到了。是啊。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. That's interesting you bring up the discipline because you are, and Sean said it, you're so driven, but you also come across as a very disciplined person. You, as I mentioned, you travel a lot. You have so many things on your plate, forgive the pun, but you do have so many things on your plate. And I wonder, do you attribute some of that to the discipline that you did learn early
现在回到节目。你提到纪律很有趣，因为你，肖恩也说了，你非常有动力，但你也给人一种非常有纪律的人的印象。你，正如我提到的，你经常旅行。你的盘子里有很多事情，请原谅这个双关语，但你的盘子里确实有很多事情。我想知道，你是否把其中一些归功于你早期学到的纪律
on from being part of a team, from being involved in sports so heavily? Yeah, I mean, listen, restaurants are dangerous games, right? When you start indulging, when you start drinking, when you start sitting down with customers and you start opening a bottle of wine and you start looking for the second, third, all of a sudden you're then a customer. And so I've got that level of discipline that is not there to be indulged. for the second, third, all of a sudden, I was with friends and the last time I ate there, would you believe, was with Coop when he was filming Burnt with Bradley.
从成为团队的一员，从如此深入地参与体育运动？是啊，我的意思是，听着，餐馆是危险的游戏，对吧？当你开始放纵，当你开始喝酒，当你开始和顾客坐在一起，你开始打开一瓶酒，你开始寻找第二瓶、第三瓶，突然间你就成了顾客。所以我有一种纪律水平，不是为了放纵。寻找第二瓶、第三瓶，突然间，我和朋友在一起，我最后一次在那里吃饭，你敢相信吗，是和库普在一起，当时他正在和布拉德利拍摄《燃情主厨》。
And we had dinner together and he said, do you come here often? I said, no, I'm embarrassed. What, of your success? No, not so much of the success. I'm just embarrassed about how plush this thing is because we never grew up with this. I created this, I worked for it,
我们一起吃了晚饭，他说，你经常来这里吗？我说，不，我很尴尬。什么，因为你的成功？不，不是因为成功。我只是对这个地方有多豪华感到尴尬，因为我们从未在这种环境中长大。我创造了这个，我为它工作，
but I don't want to indulge. I think that's the discipline coming back again. But having that opportunity to excel so early in soccer and giving yourself a sense of excellence, of now that you, well, once you came into a leadership position, did you find that you were eager to give that opportunity to your staff, whether they be a sous chef, prep chef, or, I mean,
但我不想放纵。我认为那是纪律又回来了。但拥有那么早就在足球中表现出色的机会，并给自己一种卓越感，现在你，好吧，一旦你进入了领导职位，你是否发现你渴望给你的员工提供那个机会，无论是副主厨、准备厨师，还是，我的意思是，
how did that inform the way in which you led folks? Unselfishness. And the non-control freak in me. And I suppose, you know, getting to the very top and winning that third mission star, I grew up watching my mom handle three jobs, and she was a cook in a beautiful little restaurant in Stratford, Avon. getting to the very top and winning that third mission star. I grew up watching my mum handle three jobs and she was a cook in a beautiful restaurant in Stratford-Avon. After soccer practice I'd go there and prep the veg for her.
这如何影响了你领导人们的方式？无私。以及我身上不控制狂的那一面。我想，你知道，达到顶峰并赢得那第三颗米其林星，我成长过程中看着我妈妈做三份工作，她是斯特拉特福德埃文一家漂亮小餐馆的厨师。达到顶峰并赢得那第三颗米其林星。我成长过程中看着我妈妈做三份工作，她是斯特拉特福德埃文一家漂亮小餐馆的厨师。足球训练后我会去那里帮她准备蔬菜。
It was mainstream food, but she installed that work ethic in me early. I knew when I got to the very top if I didn't delegate at the age of 33 and teach beneath me in a way that you got everyone up to that platform, I would kill myself because it is that relentless. So one minute you're playing in the orchestra, next minute you're conducting the orchestra is those 25 chefs on a daily basis, you then have to teach quickly and offload what you've got to empower the others to get on that platform. You know, it's so funny, because oftentimes when you see,
那是主流食物，但她很早就把那种职业道德灌输给了我。我知道当我达到顶峰时，如果我不在33岁时授权，并以一种让每个人都达到那个平台的方式教导我下面的人，我会自杀，因为它是如此无情。所以一分钟你在管弦乐队里演奏，下一分钟你在指挥管弦乐队，那是每天25名厨师，你必须快速教导并卸下你所拥有的，以赋予其他人权力，让他们登上那个平台。你知道，这太搞笑了，因为通常当你看到，
especially when they cut the commercials together for your various shows, they sort of cast you as the guy who's coming, you're being really hard on the people who run the restaurant, and they're quite slow, and they're dumb, and you're smart, and you're the villain, or you're the star, but you're the villain, or you're the good guy, you're saving them,
特别是当他们为你各种节目剪辑广告时，他们把你塑造成那个来的人，你对经营餐馆的人非常严厉，他们很慢，他们很笨，而你很聪明，你是反派，或者你是明星，但你是反派，或者你是好人，你在拯救他们，
but you're well- And I smart and you're the villain, or you're the star but you're the villain, or you're the good guy, you're saving them, but you're poor. And I think that there's like this, certainly before I had ever watched the show when I saw those things, the misconception I had was that that it was all ego and in fact, it's the opposite. You understand that you've actually got very, there's very little ego in it. You understand that the restaurant
但你很……而且我认为有这样一种，当然在我看节目之前，当我看到那些东西时，我的误解是这一切都是自我，事实上，恰恰相反。你明白你实际上有非常，那里几乎没有自我。你明白餐馆
or the business is the star and that everybody has to be on board, pulling towards making that thing succeed. Exactly. Otherwise, you've spent decades as a busy idiot. And I'll be honest. Seriously. Because you just spent, you know... Listen, the hours are unsociable, the money's shit on the journey up, like in any career.
或者生意才是明星，每个人都必须参与，朝着让那件事成功努力。正是如此。否则，你就是几十年的忙碌白痴。我会诚实地说。说真的。因为你只是花了，你知道……听着，工作时间是不社交的，在上升的过程中钱很少，就像任何职业一样。
And so you've got to value that process. the money's shit on the journey up like in any career. And so you've got to value that process. And so when I started realizing all these issues, it was about the lack of empowerment. You've got to get them on the same page. It's bloody frustrating when they're not listening, right? And kitchen nightmares, let's not forget, I don't rock up unannounced. They do ask me in there by the way. And they promised me they have cleaned up
所以你必须重视那个过程。在上升的过程中钱很少，就像任何职业一样。所以你必须重视那个过程。所以当我开始意识到所有这些问题时，这是关于缺乏授权。你必须让他们达成共识。当他们不听的时候，这真是太令人沮丧了，对吧？还有《厨房噩梦》，别忘了，我不是不请自来的。顺便说一下，他们确实邀请我进去。他们向我保证他们已经清理过了
before I got there and I'm thinking, holy shit, so you cleaned up and it's still a shithole. What was it like two weeks ago? Yeah, but the psychological journey that you take them on is so funny. One of the greatest one-liners you had was, you walk in there to somebody and you said, you're like a one-hit wonder, except your one-hit is fucking burnt.
在我到那儿之前，我在想，天哪，所以你清理过了，它还是个垃圾场。两周前是什么样？是啊，但你带他们经历的心理旅程太搞笑了。你拥有的最伟大的单口相声之一是，你走进那里对某人说，你就像一个昙花一现的明星，除了你的昙花一现是该死的烧焦了。
LAUGHTER Jesus. I got accused once of bringing a mouse in my pocket. No way. I think it was outside Philly in a restaurant and there was a mouse running across the floor and I said, look, we're about to open the doors. There's a fucking mouse on table seven.
笑声 天哪。我曾经被指控在口袋里带了一只老鼠。不可能。我想那是在费城外的一家餐馆，地板上有一只老鼠跑过，我说，看，我们马上就要开门了。七号桌上有一只该死的老鼠。
I said, stop it, you brought that in. I said, sorry, beg your pardon. He said, yeah, roll the cameras back. I said, what do you mean roll the cameras back? Yeah, play the tape. I said, what do you mean play the tape? I don't do that shit. Are you saying that I put this mouse in my, yeah.
我说，停下，是你带进来的。我说，抱歉，请原谅。他说，是啊，把摄像机倒回去。我说，你什么意思把摄像机倒回去？是啊，播放录像。我说，你什么意思播放录像？我不做那种事。你是说我把这只老鼠放进我的，是啊。
I saw you shake your leg as you came through the door and you shook the mouse out of your ankles. That's Ratatouille, isn't it? Honestly, I swear to God. What's the grossest, without naming it, what's the grossest situation you ever walked into in a restaurant? It's every episode.
我看到你进门时抖了抖腿，你把老鼠从脚踝处抖了出来。那是《料理鼠王》，对吧？老实说，我向上帝发誓。你走进过的餐馆里，最恶心的情况是什么，不提名字？每一集都是。
I know, but there must be one that's stuck with you that's like. Oh God. What is the situation you ever walked into in a restaurant? Oh God, I think recently I was in one restaurant, and you know, sort of the hot plate, the past, that's where everything comes to, right? And they had all these parfait jars up there with like rice and lentils and grains, and I thought one of those jars had smashed because it's full of all these little grains. And until I got up close personal, I didn't realize it was actually full of rat shit. And so I said to the chef,
我知道，但一定有一个让你印象深刻的，就像。哦，天哪。你走进过的餐馆里，最恶心的情况是什么？哦，天哪，我想最近我在一家餐馆，你知道，那种热板，传菜口，那是所有东西都来的地方，对吧？他们在那上面放了所有这些芭菲罐，里面有米饭、扁豆和谷物，我以为其中一个罐子碎了，因为它装满了所有这些小谷物。直到我近距离观察，我才意识到它实际上装满了老鼠屎。所以我对厨师说，
hey, have you seen what's on top of the pass? This stuff could be dripping into the face. Well, it's not. I said, yeah, but it's rat shit. He said, yeah, I'm going to clean it. I said, but when are you going to clean it? He said, what do you expect me to do? Fucking shoot the rats?
嘿，你看到传菜口上面有什么了吗？这些东西可能会滴进食物里。嗯，没有。我说，是啊，但那是老鼠屎。他说，是啊，我要清理它。我说，但你什么时候清理它？他说，你指望我做什么？该死地射杀老鼠吗？
I said, no, clean your shit hole. And so he was cooking food, serving it under the hot plate with all these little tiny turds that had dehydrated become like little bullets on top of the pass. Gross. Jason, Jason, God, this hurts you so much.
我说，不，清理你的垃圾场。所以他正在做饭，在热板下供应食物，上面有所有这些细小的粪便，它们已经脱水变成了像小子弹一样的东西，在传菜口上面。恶心。杰森，杰森，天哪，这让你很痛苦。
I can't, yeah. Yeah, another one-liner. Sorry, this is the last one. You said, it might have been recently, you said, you're so fucking useless, you make a bloody brick wall look intelligent. Sometimes, I don't even know if I'm coming out with them, you know that.
我不能，是啊。是啊，另一个单口相声。抱歉，这是最后一个。你说，可能是最近，你说，你真是该死的一无是处，你让一堵该死的砖墙看起来都很聪明。有时，我甚至不知道我是否说出来了，你知道吗？
Sometimes it's just in the heat of the moment. Of course, of course. They push your buttons, man. Yeah, well what really does, and if it changes, let us know, but I would imagine that your button gets pushed when you see people really not kind of rowing in the same direction, like not really being a good team member, or is it lack of work ethic or concentration? What is it that really gets you? Laziness.
有时这只是在激动的时刻。当然，当然。他们触动了你的神经，伙计。是啊，什么真的会，如果它改变了，告诉我们，但我会想象当看到人们真的没有朝着同一个方向划船，就像没有真正成为一个好的团队成员，或者是因为缺乏职业道德或专注力时，你的神经会被触动？到底是什么真的让你生气？懒惰。
Yeah. Laziness. It's the worst thing anyone can bring into any of us. gets you. Lazyness is the worst thing anyone can bring into any restaurant. Especially when you're working hard and people around you aren't where you are. Exactly that. And there are so many tiny details. And I always consider 10 little problems become one big problem at the end of the day. But when chefs start cutting corners in our business, you're screwed. It's the beginning of the end. And also, hygiene. No, but seriously, you know, there is nothing worse than a sweaty fat fuck that comes out of that kitchen
是的。懒惰。这是任何人带给我们的最糟糕的东西。懒惰是任何餐厅里最糟糕的东西。尤其是当你努力工作，而周围的人却不在状态时。正是如此。而且有太多微小的细节。我总是认为10个小问题到最后就会变成一个大问题。但当厨师在我们的行业里偷工减料时，你就完蛋了。这是走向终结的开始。还有，卫生。不，说真的，你知道，没有什么比一个汗流浃背的肥猪从厨房里出来更糟糕的了
and goes to the table and he's got dehydrated skin, he's got a beard that's untrimmed, he's sweating from the armpits, his fingernails are black, and he asks you, how was your fucking lunch? I mean, the worst question, the worst question, his fingernails are black, and he asks you, how is your fucking lunch? The worst question, first of all, you should never have sent that food if it wasn't good anyway, so don't ask that question. Secondly, it's a bad advert for the restaurant. And it's gross. And today's chefs need to be a lot more prolific, not just as a marketing tool, but just common sense.
走到餐桌前，皮肤脱水，胡子没修，腋下出汗，指甲是黑的，然后问你，你的午餐怎么样？我的意思是，最糟糕的问题，最糟糕的问题，他的指甲是黑的，然后问你，你的午餐怎么样？最糟糕的问题，首先，如果食物不好，你根本就不应该端上来，所以别问那个问题。其次，这对餐厅来说是个糟糕的广告。而且很恶心。今天的厨师需要更有成效，不仅仅是作为一种营销工具，而是常识。
And so I hate laziness, I hate slobs. I'm not good at that. Yeah, yeah, I've been around. What do you guys, I know what my pet peeves are when I walk into a restaurant, they're really pretty trivial. Do you guys have a pet peeve? Does it start with welcome in?
所以我讨厌懒惰，我讨厌邋遢的人。我不擅长那个。是啊，是啊，我经历过。你们有什么，我知道我走进餐厅时最讨厌什么，它们真的很琐碎。你们有什么讨厌的事吗？是从“欢迎光临”开始的吗？
Well, first of all, welcome in. Welcome in. If I own a restaurant, well, I do, if anybody at the Queen Beaver says welcome in? Well, first of all, welcome in. Welcome in. If I own a restaurant, whoa, I do, if anybody at the Queen Beaver says welcome in, you're gone. I fucking hate that sort of faux folksy bullshit. And it's new, right? Isn't it just like a-
嗯，首先，欢迎光临。欢迎光临。如果我拥有一家餐厅，嗯，我确实有，如果“女王海狸”里的任何人说“欢迎光临”？嗯，首先，欢迎光临。欢迎光临。如果我拥有一家餐厅，哇，我确实有，如果“女王海狸”里的任何人说“欢迎光临”，你就被解雇了。我他妈讨厌那种虚伪的乡土废话。而且这是新的，对吧？难道它不就像一个——
Have a day, it's like when you play golf, they go have a day, fuck off. Exactly. Please fuck right off. That took over for touch base and circle back. Circle back, yeah. Welcome in is gone, but also when a waiter says, so tonight chef is preparing, I'm like,
祝你有美好的一天，就像你打高尔夫球时，他们说祝你有美好的一天，滚蛋吧。正是如此。请他妈的滚远点。那取代了“建立联系”和“回头再聊”。回头再聊，是的。“欢迎光临”已经过时了，但当服务员说，今晚厨师准备了，我就觉得，
I don't know chef, so stop referring to, and chef is doing a braised beef again. Or it's going to be. It's gonna be, yes. It's gonna be put on a plate, oh is it? I hope so. Yeah, or soup of the day, what was it? Well, it's a roasted carrot and cumin,
我不认识厨师，所以别再提了，厨师又在做炖牛肉了。或者它将是。它将是，是的。它将被放在盘子里，哦，是吗？我希望如此。是的，或者今日例汤，是什么？嗯，是烤胡萝卜和孜然，
and what was the soup of the day yesterday? Roasted carrot and cumin. And what was the soup last week? Roasted carrot and cumin. So it's soup of the fucking month. And isn't soup really just sauce? Can we dispel the whole... It really is sauce, right? It's salty, it's creamy. Like you can put it over a chicken breast. No, no, no, no, no. I mean, soups are magical. I remember going to Paris at the age of 22, I said to you earlier,
昨天今日例汤是什么？烤胡萝卜和孜然。上周的汤是什么？烤胡萝卜和孜然。所以这是他妈的月度例汤。汤难道不就是酱汁吗？我们能消除整个……它确实是酱汁，对吧？它是咸的，奶油味的。就像你可以把它浇在鸡胸肉上。不，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，汤是神奇的。我记得22岁时去巴黎，我刚才跟你说过，
without a pot to piss in, and I had to become French. And not only was I running away from the hurt in soccer, but I just wanted to memorize myself in France and become French. And my first job on the Galmanger, the sort of starter section, was making this broccoli soup with goat's cheese ravioli. So they gave me these heads of broccoli and a pan of water. And I thought we'd need garlic, shallots, vegetable stock, but all it was was rolling, boiling, beautiful water,
穷得叮当响，我必须变得像个法国人。我不仅是在逃避足球带来的伤害，我只是想让自己沉浸在法国，成为法国人。我在冷菜部的第一份工作，也就是前菜部分，是做这个西兰花汤配山羊奶酪饺子。他们给了我这些西兰花头和一锅水。我以为我们需要大蒜、红葱头、蔬菜高汤，但所有的东西只是翻滚、沸腾、美丽的开水，
nicely seasoned, the florets, the little flowers of broccoli, cooked for two minutes so we didn't lose the color. Then you drain those broccoli florets, and then from there you use the water the broccoli was cooked in, and you puree the broccoli and add the water back to it, and it's most natural, delicious, flavored broccoli soup. Two ingredients, broccoli and water.
调味得当，西兰花的小花蕾，煮了两分钟，这样我们就不会失去颜色。然后你把那些西兰花蕾沥干，然后从那里你使用煮西兰花的水，把西兰花打成泥，再把水加回去，这是最天然、美味、风味十足的西兰花汤。两种配料，西兰花和水。
And then of course it gets sent into the Premier League with those little tiny goat's cheese raviolis. And it was so beautifully done. So no, soup is not a fucking sauce. No, it's not. And Sean, just for Sean, broccoli is a vegetable. Yeah, hang on. It looks like a tree.
然后当然，它会被送进英超联赛，配上那些小小的山羊奶酪饺子。它做得太美了。所以不，汤不是他妈的酱汁。不，它不是。还有肖恩，只是对肖恩说，西兰花是一种蔬菜。是的，等等。它看起来像棵树。
Yeah, it's got a pop tart flavor. All right. Now, Gordon, why, my mother is British and she was always sort of just like, well, you know, Britain was never really known for its great food, she would always say. Why is that, and I hear that it has changed now. Can you walk us through that?
是的，它有一种果酱馅饼的味道。好了。现在，戈登，为什么，我母亲是英国人，她总是说，嗯，你知道，英国从来没有以美食闻名，她总是这么说。为什么会这样，我听说现在已经改变了。你能带我们了解一下吗？
Yeah, I mean, I got the piss and the Mickey taken out of me. Yeah, when I was in Paris in the 90s, because we had such a bad reputation. Yeah, it was like roast beef, fish and chips, mushy peas, and it was dreadful. It was gray, it was dark, it was fucking horrendous. Because it was heavily influenced from? I think it was the mining, the mining towns,
是的，我的意思是，我被嘲笑和戏弄了。是的，当我在90年代在巴黎时，因为我们名声太差了。是的，就像烤牛肉、炸鱼薯条、糊状豌豆，太可怕了。它是灰色的，它是暗淡的，它他妈的太糟糕了。因为它深受什么影响？我想是采矿，矿业城镇，
in a way that it was like meat and two veg, and it was that sort of uninspired way of cooking with just absolute crap. And so I couldn't wait to get out of the UK to go and sort of get on that journey and start searching. And so France was, it was this bedrock. You get birthed at a cuisine. And then from France I went to Italy,
以一种肉加两种蔬菜的方式，那是一种毫无灵感的烹饪方式，简直就是垃圾。所以我迫不及待地想离开英国，去踏上那段旅程，开始寻找。所以法国是，它是这个基石。你诞生于一种烹饪。然后从法国我去了意大利，
from Italy I went to Spain, and then from Spain I came across and spent a year on this incredible yacht, traveling around the world, picking up multiple cultures. So now the UK is this stunning melting pot. We're central Europe, we're 26 miles away from France, and it's got some of the best, best food in Europe now. We can rub shoulders with the French.
从意大利我去了西班牙，然后从西班牙我过来，在这一艘令人难以置信的游艇上待了一年，环游世界，吸收了多种文化。所以现在英国是一个令人惊叹的大熔炉。我们是中欧，我们离法国只有26英里，它现在拥有欧洲最好、最好的食物。我们可以与法国人并肩。
We can rub shoulders in the US. And yeah, it's a nation to be proud of now. Not to get political, but do you think Brexit kind of is dulling the cuisine influence? I think it's putting a bit of a sort of wedge between those incredible countries. The crossover was beautiful. I love a wedge.
我们可以在美国并肩。是的，这是一个现在值得骄傲的国家。不是要谈论政治，但你认为英国脱欧是否在削弱烹饪的影响力？我认为它在那些令人难以置信的国家之间制造了一点隔阂。那种交叉是非常美丽的。我喜欢楔形沙拉。
With blue cheese and bacon, sorry. Oh shit. So yeah, I never get into politics. I stay out of that shit because customers come to be neutral and to break bread without some chef spouting out. But the influence of all of those countries that are so close to England, I'm sure, helped to influence the cuisine there. Massively.
配蓝纹奶酪和培根，抱歉。哦，该死。所以是的，我从不涉足政治。我远离那些狗屁，因为顾客来这里是为了保持中立，为了掰开面包，而不是听厨师喋喋不休。但所有那些离英国如此近的国家的文化影响，我相信，确实帮助影响了那里的烹饪。非常大。
But no longer. Massively. What would you say, would you, later, Raso, explain if you can for our listener, when an Englishman describes having his dinner, his supper, his tea, and where they all fit, and what time of day they fit, and how they can be distinguished one from the other. Yeah, that's a great question. First of all, I went to school with porridge,
但现在不再是了。非常大。你会怎么说，你会，稍后，拉索，如果可以的话，为我们的听众解释一下，当一个英国人描述吃他的晚餐、宵夜、茶点时，它们都在哪里，它们在一天中的什么时间，以及它们如何相互区分。是的，这是一个很好的问题。首先，我上学时吃的是粥，
which is your oatmeal, right? We didn't use milk, we used it with salt. I remember my father saying to me once that you're going to be making your oatmeal with salt. And I said, dad, why then lunch is just a basic sandwich, and then you come home for your tea. And tea is a dinner, but it's called tea, because you never asked for dinner. Dinner was a posh word.
也就是你们的燕麦片，对吧？我们不用牛奶，我们用盐。我记得我父亲有一次对我说，你要用盐做燕麦片。我说，爸爸，为什么？然后午餐只是一个简单的三明治，然后你回家吃茶点。茶点就是晚餐，但它被称为茶点，因为你从不要求晚餐。晚餐是一个时髦的词。
You went home for tea, and sometimes that would be a jam sandwich, sometimes that could be fish and chips, steak and kidney pie, but you had your tea. And back in those days, you just, you got what your mom served you, right? You never questioned that. Is that not traditionally at four o'clock?
你回家吃茶点，有时那会是一个果酱三明治，有时可能是炸鱼薯条、牛排腰子派，但你吃了你的茶点。在那些日子里，你只是，你得到你妈妈给你端上来的东西，对吧？你从不质疑。那不是传统上在四点钟吗？
I know, I think you're thinking of the sort of high tea, the afternoon tea. That's different. Oh, that's what I thought it was. Yeah, so yeah, tea's dinner. So you hear like a guy coming back, especially 50, 60 years ago, a guy would come back from, when they used to have the coal mines
我知道，我想你想到的是那种下午茶，下午茶。那是不同的。哦，我以为是那个。是的，所以是的，茶点就是晚餐。所以你听到像一个家伙回来，特别是50、60年前，一个家伙会回来，当他们还有煤矿的时候
and that's all gone now, but they'd come back and he'd say, you know, would come back, go home to have his tea, right, Gordon? Is that what it is? That's exactly that, going home for tea. Yeah. Does the United States, in your opinion, have elevated cuisine at all?
现在都没了，但他们会回来，他会说，你知道，会回来，回家吃他的茶点，对吧，戈登？是这样吗？正是那样，回家吃茶点。是的。在你看来，美国有高级烹饪吗？
I mean, like, you're just- Oh my God, definitely. Yeah. Absolutely, definitely, without a doubt. Yeah, okay. I mean, you always have to go to the cities, like the big cities, to get it, right? Yeah, I think the biggest shock when I first came over here
我的意思是，就像，你只是——哦，天哪，绝对有。是的。绝对，肯定，毫无疑问。是的，好吧。我的意思是，你总是必须去城市，像大城市，才能吃到，对吧？是的，我想我刚来这里时最大的震惊
years ago was just the size of the breakfast. Yeah. And then on the side of the breakfast, you've got a fucking fruit salad on your breakfast as well. So it turns into like a mini dessert. That's not the way you want to start the day, right? Oh my God. They say it's the most important meal of the day,
几年前，早餐的份量太大了。是的。然后在早餐旁边，你早餐还有一份他妈的水果沙拉。所以它变成了一个迷你甜点。这不是你想开始一天的方式，对吧？哦，天哪。他们说这是最重要的一餐，
but it should be your lightest meal of the day. And then you build up to that. But chefs are notorious for sort of eating, because we graze. So everyone says, you're not eating? You're not hungry? No, we've just grown up grazing, because if you don't taste everything before it goes out,
但它应该是你一天中最轻的一餐。然后你再慢慢增加。但厨师们以吃东西而闻名，因为我们边做边吃。所以每个人都说，你不吃吗？你不饿吗？不，我们从小就是这样边做边吃的，因为如果你不在食物端出去之前尝遍所有东西，
then how do you perfect that level of utter, beautiful, stunning food? So we have small spoons, and so I can't go out and eat. I think, well, last time. So we have small spoons. And so I can't go out and eat. I think, Will, last time you saw me, you're just picking, you're not eating properly. Do you have an eating disorder? I'm like, no, no.
那你怎么能完善那种极致、美丽、令人惊叹的食物水平呢？所以我们有小勺子，所以我不能出去吃。我想，嗯，上次。所以我们有小勺子。所以我不能出去吃。我想，威尔，上次你见到我时，你只是在挑食，你没有好好吃饭。你有饮食失调吗？我说，不，不。
We just can't eat starter, apps, main dessert. Yeah, you did it, that's exactly right. You didn't go through the whole thing, you just now sort of little bits and pieces. Gordon, I work a bit in Atlanta and I'm always really surprised. Oh, here we go, plugging in Atlanta again. And excited about how great the restaurants are there.
我们只是不能吃前菜、开胃菜、主菜、甜点。是的，你做到了，那完全正确。你没有经历整个过程，你只是现在吃点零碎的东西。戈登，我在亚特兰大工作了一点，我总是感到非常惊讶。哦，开始了，又在为亚特兰大做广告了。并且对那里的餐厅有多棒感到兴奋。
What's the last city that surprised you in the States with its cuisine? I'd say Austin, Austin, Texas. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. Powerful, oh my goodness me. And I mean, I'm just talking about barbecue. There's some incredible ethnic restaurants there
在美国，最近一个让你感到惊讶的城市是什么？我会说是奥斯汀，德克萨斯州的奥斯汀。哦，真的吗？是的，是的。强大，哦，我的天哪。我的意思是，我只是在谈论烧烤。那里有一些令人难以置信的民族餐厅
and from Filipino to great Greek restaurants and Japanese, Asian inspired, yeah, Austin, Texas. What other than naturally French cuisine, which is sort of almost like the sort of the granddaddy of them all in a way, and other than going out for that, what is the, what is your sort of guilty pleasure meal to go out for that you're like, just go and have a Chinese or whatever, you know what I mean? Yeah, I mean, you know, I spent three years training in France,
从菲律宾菜到很棒的希腊餐厅和日本菜，亚洲风味，是的，德克萨斯州的奥斯汀。除了天然的法国菜，它在某种程度上几乎是所有菜系的鼻祖，除了出去吃那个，你出去吃的所谓“罪恶快感”餐是什么，你会觉得，就去吃个中餐什么的，你明白我的意思吗？是的，我的意思是，你知道，我在法国训练了三年，
that's two years in Paris and a year down the south of France. And I absolutely adore France. It's just the French, I can't fucking stand. Don't worry, they're not listening. Do you speak French? I do, yes, I do. Do you speak Italian too and Spanish? Yeah, but not fluent. The French is where it's at and we still got Russians.
那是两年在巴黎，一年在法国南部。我绝对崇拜法国。只是法国人，我他妈受不了。别担心，他们没在听。你会说法语吗？我会，是的，我会。你也会说意大利语和西班牙语吗？是的，但不流利。法语才是关键，我们还有俄罗斯人。
Gordon, I had a French waiter once say to me, I said, everybody else is ordering drinks. I said, I have a Diet Coke. And he goes, ah, American champagne. I was like, hey, fuck you. Fuck you, dude. They just have the most romantic ways of describing food. We have grilled cheese, cheese and toast.
戈登，我曾经有一个法国服务员对我说，我说，其他人都在点饮料。我说，我要一杯健怡可乐。他说，啊，美国香槟。我当时想，嘿，去你妈的。去你妈的，伙计。他们只是有最浪漫的方式来描述食物。我们有烤奶酪，奶酪吐司。
They have fucking cote monsieur. We have mashed potatoes. They have pommes puree. We have apple pie. They have a d'artre au pomme. But it is good. It is delicious. So other than French cuisine, what's your guilty pleasure?
他们有他妈的火腿奶酪三明治。我们有土豆泥。他们有土豆泥。我们有苹果派。他们有苹果塔。但它确实很好。它很美味。所以除了法国菜，你的罪恶快感是什么？
What's your thing that you're like, oh, I'm going to go and have that? Oh, God. I'm a big fan of In-N-Out Burger. I love burgers, honestly. Yeah, I do too. A great smash burger. I just love burgers.
你的那种你会觉得，哦，我要去吃那个的东西是什么？哦，天哪。我是In-N-Out汉堡的忠实粉丝。我真的喜欢汉堡。是的，我也喜欢。一个很棒的碎肉汉堡。我就是喜欢汉堡。
I absolutely adore burgers. Did that just start, the smash burger? And what it is literally, you just make the patty not fat and juicy, you make it thin and little. Cameralized, yeah. And they smash it once. Social media has popularized it for sure.
我绝对崇拜汉堡。那是刚开始的吗，碎肉汉堡？它字面上就是，你只是让肉饼不那么肥厚多汁，你让它变得又薄又小。焦糖化，是的。他们把它压碎一次。社交媒体肯定让它流行起来了。
And the bun, the bun too, right? So it kind of becomes a little bit more sort of dense. Like a sandwich, because whenever I would go to a hotel and order, it'd be gigantic, the burger, and you couldn't even get your mouth there, and then it was like a mess. They ask you how you want it cooked. Jesus, Sean, your blood pressure's going up, relax, okay?
还有面包，面包也是，对吧？所以它变得有点更致密了。就像三明治，因为每当我走进一家酒店点餐时，它都巨大无比，那个汉堡，你甚至没法把嘴凑过去，然后它就像一团糟。他们问你想要几分熟。天哪，肖恩，你的血压升高了，放松点，好吗？
They're going to fix the burger. But also you get a much better camera-ization on that smash burger because you roll it and then literally smash it immediately. The minute it's being pressed onto that griddle. And then literally 90 seconds each side, it's camera-ized, it's juicy. And you can do a double stack on that as well. And really identify the flavor that means. What dish are you most proud of?
他们会修好汉堡的。而且你在那个碎肉汉堡上能得到更好的焦糖化，因为你把它滚圆，然后字面上立即压碎它。就在它被压在那个煎锅上的那一刻。然后字面上每面90秒，它就焦糖化了，它很多汁。你也可以在上面做双层。并真正确定那意味着的味道。你最引以为傲的菜是什么？
What dish do you think you make because you make so many? What dish do you think you make really well? And it could be as simple as an omelette. What's the thing that you most proud of? What dish do you think you make, because you make so many, what dish do you think you make really well? And it could be as simple as an omelet. What's the thing that you do really well? In your opinion. There's two things. When we took over Clarities back in 2004, I sort of reintroduced the fillet of beef Wellington,
你认为你做的菜，因为你做了这么多？你认为你做得很好的菜是什么？它可以简单到像一个煎蛋卷。你最引以为傲的东西是什么？你认为你做的菜，因为你做了这么多，你认为你做得很好的菜是什么？它可以简单到像一个煎蛋卷。你做得很好的东西是什么？在你看来。有两件事。当我们2004年接管Clarities时，我重新引入了菲力惠灵顿牛排，
which is a showstopper. And that's just like your perfect sort of go-to. That's like beef in a pastry, right? Yeah, I love that. You know what it is? I don't think I've ever had it. I'll send you one. Delicious.
那是一个压轴戏。那就像你完美的去处。那就像酥皮里的牛肉，对吧？是的，我喜欢那个。你知道那是什么吗？我想我从来没吃过。我给你寄一个。美味。
And then second is scrambled eggs. Scrambled eggs for me are so important. Because anything rubber, anything overcooked, undercooked, there's nothing worse, honestly. And then every time I see chefs put fucking eggs in a microwave, I scream. I just, oh no. Some of the best scrambled eggs I ever had in my life
然后第二是炒蛋。对我来说，炒蛋非常重要。因为任何橡胶状的、煮过头的、没煮熟的，没有什么比这更糟糕的了，说真的。然后每次我看到厨师把他妈的鸡蛋放进微波炉，我就尖叫。我只是，哦不。我一生中吃过的一些最好的炒蛋
was at the Hotel Georges Sainte-Franc. Oh, there you go. Amazing. Of course. And I asked the guy. They put a little cream in it, right? Well, I asked the guy, I said, how do you get them so soft and creamy? And I don't know if he's joking with me.
是在乔治圣弗朗酒店。哦，那不就对了。太棒了。当然。我问那个家伙。他们在里面加了一点奶油，对吧？嗯，我问那个家伙，我说，你是怎么让它们变得这么软、这么奶油味的？我不知道他是不是在跟我开玩笑。
Go fuck yourself. Go fuck yourself. With just a dash of go fuck yourself. With all these questions, stupid Americans, shut up. You like to know the magic? In French it's fat foot foot. Yeah. Fat foot foot?
去你妈的。去你妈的。只加了一点去你妈的。带着所有这些问题，愚蠢的美国人，闭嘴。你想知道魔法吗？在法语里是fat foot foot。是的。Fat foot foot？
Yes. What does that mean? Go fuck yourself. Go fuck yourself. Wait, but so I don't know if he was joking, he said American cheese, right? And I'm like, no, that can't be. What?
是的。那是什么意思？去你妈的。去你妈的。等等，但我不知道他是不是在开玩笑，他说美国奶酪，对吧？我当时想，不，那不可能。什么？
I come home, listen to this, I come home, I make scrambled eggs soft scrambled eggs really slow be. I come home, listen to this, I come home, I make scrambled eggs, soft scrambled eggs, really slow, and I put Kraft singles in them. It's incredible. Let me tell you, let me tell you, I'm going to make it for you. It's incredible. Gordon just punched a hole in the wall.
我回家，听着，我回家，我做炒蛋，软炒蛋，非常慢。我回家，听着，我回家，我做炒蛋，软炒蛋，非常慢，我把卡夫单片奶酪放进去。太不可思议了。让我告诉你，让我告诉你，我要为你做。太不可思议了。戈登刚才在墙上打了一个洞。
It makes it sweet and creamy. Somebody once put a little cottage cheese in scrambled eggs. And it was pretty good. No, no, no. The secret behind any great scrambled egg is stopping the cooking. Because if you don't stop the cooking, they'll just overcook and turn into rubber. So it's a teaspoon of creme fraiche
它让它变得甜美和奶油味。有人曾经在炒蛋里放了一点白干酪。而且还挺好吃的。不，不，不。任何伟大炒蛋背后的秘密是停止烹饪。因为如果你不停止烹饪，它们就会煮过头变成橡胶。所以是一茶匙法式酸奶油
or a little tablespoon of cream. And that just slows the process down. All right. Sean, he was fucking with you. He just wanted to keep you in America. He wanted you to go home and stay home. You know what the one thing I do like, here's my guilty pleasure eggs, I will say this. My guilty pleasure eggs in Southern California especially
或者一小汤匙奶油。那只是减慢了过程。好了。肖恩，他在他妈的耍你。他只是想让你留在美国。他想让你回家并待在家里。你知道我确实喜欢的一件事，这是我的罪恶快感鸡蛋，我会这么说。我的罪恶快感鸡蛋，特别是在南加州
and it is chorizo and eggs with a little bit of cheese. Yes, they're beautiful. I love these. Beautiful. Fantastic. And corned beef hash. Yeah, they get eggs. We can eat breakfast, lunch and dinner.
是墨西哥香肠炒蛋，加一点奶酪。是的，它们很美。我喜欢这些。美丽。太棒了。还有咸牛肉碎。是的，他们有鸡蛋。我们可以吃早餐、午餐和晚餐。
That's the nice thing about eggs. That's the simplicity behind eggs. And it's something I taught all the kids, our kids to make from the ages of six, great scrambled eggs. And is it true that the cholesterol in eggs has been dispelled? They're fine for you is what I hear?
这就是鸡蛋的好处。这就是鸡蛋背后的简单性。这是我教所有孩子，我们的孩子从六岁起就做的事情，很棒的炒蛋。鸡蛋里的胆固醇已经被消除了，这是真的吗？我听说它们对你没问题？
Or what do you know? Yeah, it's the balance, isn't it? I mean, you don't eat that every day. So we'll do scrambled eggs maybe at the weekend, Saturday or Sunday. Okay. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show.
或者你知道什么？是的，这是平衡，不是吗？我的意思是，你不会每天都吃那个。所以我们可能在周末，周六或周日做炒蛋。好的。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。
Wait, but go back to your kids, because you have six kids. Good for you. Six children, and I read that you missed the births of your first four kids on purpose, is that right? Well, hold on, you're going to get me into shit here. Let's make one thing absolutely clear, okay? I know, but my wife didn get me into shit here. Let's make one thing absolutely clear, okay? I know, but my wife didn't want me in there.
等等，回到你的孩子，因为你有六个孩子。为你高兴。六个孩子，我读到你故意错过了你前四个孩子的出生，这是真的吗？嗯，等等，你这是要让我陷入麻烦。让我们把一件事说得绝对清楚，好吗？我知道，但我的妻子没有——你这是要让我陷入麻烦。让我们把一件事说得绝对清楚，好吗？我知道，但我的妻子不想让我进去。
She said, first of all, I want my mom and your mom in here. You're not going to fucking see me in that state, okay? And nobody on that side of the curtain, get out of there. So that was her decision. I had to respect that decision. And then when I did finally arrive in the theater for our fifth baby, I fucking clapped like a wimp. And I blacked out holding Oscar in the air.
她说，首先，我想要我妈和你妈在这里。你他妈的不会看到我处于那种状态，好吗？帘子那边没有人，滚出去。所以那是她的决定。我必须尊重那个决定。然后当我终于到达产房迎接我们的第五个孩子时，我他妈像个懦夫一样鼓掌。我在空中抱着奥斯卡时晕倒了。
Yes. I was so fucked. Holding the baby? But they said, what do you want to listen to? It was coming through the sun roof. And so there was a lot of commotions going on. It was a C-section? Yes.
是的。我太他妈糟糕了。抱着孩子？但他们说，你想听什么？它正从天窗传出来。所以发生了很多骚动。那是剖腹产吗？是的。
Yeah, yeah, I've been there. Did you call that the sun roof? Yeah. I've been for all three, all three of my sons. I've been there. Did you call that the sun room? Yeah. I've been for all three, all three of my sons. I said, oh, can you play Ed Sheeran? So they started playing Ed. If you turn up the volume, I can hear all these noises.
是的，是的，我经历过。你管那个叫天窗吗？是的。我经历了所有三次，我所有的三个儿子。我经历了。你管那个叫天窗吗？是的。我经历了所有三次，我所有的三个儿子。我说，哦，你能放艾德·希兰的歌吗？所以他们开始放艾德。如果你调大音量，我能听到所有这些声音。
Turn up the volume. And all of a sudden, I saw two more doctors dive in. I looked on the floor and there was blood everywhere. Oh, God. And all of a sudden, they popped him out and then they came straight over to me and I went, whoa, whoa, whoa, shit. Yeah. And I sat back and then I clapped like a fucking idiot.
调大音量。突然间，我看到另外两个医生冲了进来。我看向地板，到处都是血。哦，天哪。突然间，他们把他弄了出来，然后他们直接朝我走来，我说，哇，哇，哇，该死。是的。我坐回原处，然后我像个他妈的白痴一样鼓掌。
Oh, I was moving. My second son, they came through on the radio, you could just hear very low, young hearts be free to the house. Love that song. I know, me too, it was so bizarre. That's great. And then, Gord, how do you, forgive me for asking,
哦，我在动。我的第二个儿子，他们通过收音机传过来，你只能听到非常低的声音，年轻的心在房子里自由。喜欢那首歌。我知道，我也是，太离奇了。太棒了。然后，戈登，你是怎么，原谅我这么问，
but I think it's incredible you have all of these business ventures, you just go, go, go, the drive, the ambition, Gord, how do you, forgive me for asking, but I think it's incredible you have all of these business ventures, you just go, go, go, the drive, the ambition, the success. How do you, what is your rules of balancing all of the family life and the work life? Yeah, that's a great question. So balance is critical. We got the right kind of support.
但我认为你拥有所有这些商业冒险真是不可思议，你只是冲、冲、冲，动力，野心，戈登，你是怎么，原谅我这么问，但我认为你拥有所有这些商业冒险真是不可思议，你只是冲、冲、冲，动力，野心，成功。你是怎么，你平衡所有家庭生活和工作生活的规则是什么？是的，这是一个很好的问题。所以平衡是至关重要的。我们有正确的支持。
Every time we were filming throughout the US, the kids would come with us, and then we would take them out of school two weeks early, put them back two weeks late, so we'd do the sort of filming schedules throughout the U.S. She's an incredible police officer back in London. Oh, that's great. Then we have the twins at 25, Jack's a Royal Marine Commando, Holly's into her fashion. And then there's Matilda, who's 23,
每次我们在美国各地拍摄时，孩子们都会和我们一起，然后我们会让他们提前两周离开学校，晚两周回去，所以我们在美国各地进行那种拍摄时间表。她在伦敦是一名出色的警察。哦，那太棒了。然后我们有25岁的双胞胎，杰克是皇家海军陆战队突击队员，霍莉从事时尚行业。然后是23岁的玛蒂尔达，
who's literally just come back from culinary school, would you believe, in a beautiful school called Bally Maloe. I am a little bit miffed the fact that she didn't ask me to train her. Sure. She's gone off elsewhere to come back to the fold. Yeah, she's seen the shows, that's the problem. So it sounds like you made all your, did all your kids have, did they all work sort of as they were growing up
她字面上刚从烹饪学校回来，你敢相信吗，在一所美丽的学校叫Bally Maloe。我确实有点生气，因为她没有让我训练她。当然。她去别处转了一圈又回到了怀抱。是的，她看过节目，这就是问题所在。所以听起来你让所有的，你的孩子都有，他们都在成长过程中工作过，
and have jobs and do things and have direction? Yeah, yeah. And you always make them fly coach or something? 100%. And I tried to explain to them what they could do with the money when they land, because we're all getting on and getting off together, so I understand the difference. And secondly, no disrespect, an eight-year-old or a 10-year-old, they don't need fucking business class or first class what they could do with the money when they land.
并且有工作，做事情，有方向？是的，是的。而且你总是让他们坐经济舱什么的？100%。我试着向他们解释当他们落地时他们可以用钱做什么，因为我们都在一起上飞机和下飞机，所以我明白区别。其次，没有不尊重，一个八岁或十岁的孩子，他们不需要他妈的商务舱或头等舱，当他们落地时他们可以用钱做什么。
Oh, the bread's so hot up front. Here's a couple. I'll be right back. I'll be back in about an hour to check on you. Yeah. I know. I just said, turn fucking right and do not disturb us for the next 12 hours. You're really, you're doing them a service though. They're really, you're, because otherwise you're depriving your kids of learning how
哦，前面的面包太热了。给你几个。我马上回来。我大约一小时后回来看看你们。是的。我知道。我只是说，他妈的向右转，接下来的12个小时不要打扰我们。你真的，你是在为他们服务。他们真的，你，因为否则你是在剥夺你的孩子学习如何
to live life and how to do things if you don't, if you don't provide that for them, I think. Yeah. And also removing the hunger, right? Yeah. And so it's not about selling at school with A stars and A's everywhere. It's about creating individuals. Well, give them a direction of something that they want to do, right?
生活和做事的机会，如果你不，如果你不为他们提供那个，我想。是的。还有消除饥饿感，对吧？是的。所以这不是关于在学校里到处都是A星和A。这是关于创造个体。嗯，给他们一个他们想做的方向，对吧？
And values, Will. Give them the values, install those values, and they can't depend on the moment that. I'm not perfect at it, I'm not suggesting that I am. But I'm sure. You know, because I got Netchettes on the other line, they want to talk to you about your parents next week. No, but I mean, look, you've got your daughter,
还有价值观，威尔。给他们价值观，灌输那些价值观，他们不能依赖那一刻。我在这方面并不完美，我不是在暗示我是。但我肯定。你知道，因为我有Netchettes在另一条线上，他们下周想和你谈谈你的父母。不，但我的意思是，看，你有你的女儿，
you got her into directing and she came and worked on your show and you got her sort of into the thing and give an address to it. I got my kids are working this summer, they're teenagers, they've got jobs. Give them a start and then see what they do with it. Exactly, I want them to have an idea of what it takes to make their own living and take care of themselves.
你让她去导演，她来你的节目工作，你让她进入那个领域并给它一个地址。我的孩子这个夏天在工作，他们是青少年，他们有工作。给他们一个开始，然后看看他们用它做什么。正是如此，我希望他们对维持自己的生活和照顾自己需要什么有一个概念。
I work at a furniture shop. We don't care. How many times? How's that mic still on? Fucking unreal, Gordon's here, and he's talking about his family. You're just trying to fucking face it. Trying to speak, let the guys, he's our guest.
我在家具店工作。我们不在乎。多少次了？那个麦克风怎么还开着？他妈的太不真实了，戈登在这里，他在谈论他的家庭。你只是在试图他妈的面对它。试图说话，让伙计们，他是我们的客人。
I didn't know what I was doing. Gordon, how do you feel, you know, so the restaurant business, you know, you love, you killed it, and then you get into the television business, you know it, you love it, you're killing it. Is there a similarity between the two? Is there an appeal that is shared with both, or do you love one over the other,
我不知道我在做什么。戈登，你感觉如何，你知道，所以餐厅生意，你知道，你热爱，你做得很好，然后你进入电视行业，你知道它，你热爱它，你做得很好。两者之间有相似之处吗？两者之间有共同的吸引力吗，或者你更喜欢其中一个，
or how does that all fit in for you? Yeah, that's a good question. I mean, I think it's the level of creativity, I think, that I enjoy most about the TV. I hate it when shows are cancelled, so I'm always a firm believer in taking your own show down first before you get cancelled. And so, there's nothing worse than when something gets cancelled.
或者这一切对你来说是如何契合的？是的，这是一个好问题。我的意思是，我认为这是我最喜欢电视的创造力水平。我讨厌节目被取消，所以我一直坚定地相信在被取消之前先撤下自己的节目。所以，没有什么比某事被取消更糟糕的了。
So fuck it, I'll come up with a better idea so you don't take me down and replace me with that. Also, I think not standing still. I think that's one thing, growing up watching Mum handle three jobs. Even on Christmas Day, we wouldn't see her to 5 p.m. in the afternoon because I knew she was coming in from the night shift working in a hospital. So you grow up with that work ethic. And I mentioned it earlier, you know, not just the fear of not having it there one day,
所以去他妈的，我会想出一个更好的主意，这样你就不会把我撤下并用那个取代我。此外，我认为不要停滞不前。我认为这是一件事，从小看着妈妈做三份工作。即使在圣诞节那天，我们也要到下午5点才能见到她，因为我知道她是从医院的夜班回来。所以你带着那种职业道德长大。我刚才提到了，你知道，不仅仅是害怕有一天没有它，
but just the value you have, where you are, and how long it's taken to master your craft. And that crossover into the TV world is sort of hand in glove, because it's real, okay? The shows are real, I take it serious. It's not about light camera action. I'm not a big fan of the shiny floor stuff. I love the raw stuff, if I'm honest. Oh, Rob is mad at you for saying that.
而是你拥有的价值，你在哪里，以及掌握你的手艺花了多长时间。而进入电视世界的交叉就像手套一样，因为它是真实的，好吗？节目是真实的，我认真对待。这不是关于灯光摄像机动作。我不是那种闪亮地板东西的忠实粉丝。如果我诚实的话，我喜欢原始的东西。哦，罗伯因为你这么说而生你的气。
So, he's always mad at me. He loves the shiny floor. I know, but even when we are on the shiny floor, I want to keep it real, okay? I want to keep it really real. Right, right. Are you able to just stop and enjoy the fruits of your labor and all the success?
所以，他总是对我生气。他喜欢闪亮的地板。我知道，但即使我们在闪亮的地板上，我也想保持真实，好吗？我想保持非常真实。对，对。你能够停下来享受你的劳动成果和所有的成功吗？
I mean, because every time we talk about your shows and your work, you just, you love what you do and you go, like you said, you just go, go, go. Are you able to just stop and go, wow, look at this and actually vacation and calm down for a bit? And pat yourself on the back. Yeah, I'm not very good at patting myself on the back of my mind.
我的意思是，因为每次我们谈论你的节目和你的工作，你只是，你热爱你所做的事情，你就像你说的那样，你只是冲、冲、冲。你能够停下来，哇，看看这个，实际上去度假，冷静一下吗？并拍拍自己的背。是的，我不擅长拍自己的背。
What I do do when I'm off, I'm off. Every six months there's either an Ironman or a marathon and so there's this sort of date that I build up to. My next Ironman is coming. It's an Ironman? An Ironman, it's a race. A Triathlon. Triathlon.
我确实做的是当我休息时，我就休息。每六个月要么有一个铁人赛要么有一个马拉松，所以有一个我建立起来的日期。我的下一个铁人赛要来了。是铁人赛？铁人赛，这是一场比赛。铁人三项。铁人三项。
Oh, got it, got it. And so my wife competes as well. She loves it. We spend a lot of time together swimming, cycling, and running, and so we have that nice little balance. Do you have a first gear? Do you ever shift down? No, but I mean, a lot of people are scared of that level of exercise.
哦，明白了，明白了。所以我的妻子也参加比赛。她喜欢它。我们花很多时间在一起游泳、骑自行车和跑步，所以我们有那种很好的小平衡。你有第一档吗？你曾经降档吗？不，但我的意思是，很多人害怕那种运动水平。
For me, it's a way of relaxing. I know it sounds crazy, but it is a way. Sean, is that what keeps you, is it fear? Yeah, yeah, yeah, just fear of exercising. Yeah. Might start sweating. Fear of exercising. Yeah, I don't want to sweat. That's impressive. What's your strongest sport or what's your weakest?
对我来说，这是一种放松的方式。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但它确实是一种方式。肖恩，这就是让你保持，是恐惧吗？是的，是的，是的，只是害怕运动。是的。可能会开始出汗。害怕运动。是的，我不想出汗。这令人印象深刻。你最强的运动是什么，或者你最弱的是什么？
The swim and the bike are strong. No, everyone's tracers out over the swim. And to be honest, everyone overworks that swim to shave two minutes off their time, which is crazy. I remember sitting in the deep water start in Hawaii for Kona Ironman, and there's two and a half thousand athletes, we had to swim out 200 meters and then wade, you know, tread water for 10 minutes before the cannon went off at half five in the morning. and there's two and a half thousand athletes who had to swim out 200 meters and then wade,
游泳和自行车很强。不，每个人都在游泳上追踪。老实说，每个人都过度训练游泳以缩短两分钟的时间，这太疯狂了。我记得坐在夏威夷科纳铁人赛的深水起点，有两千五百名运动员，我们必须游出200米，然后涉水，你知道，在早上五点半炮声响起前踩水10分钟。有两千五百名运动员必须游出200米，然后涉水，
tread water for 10 minutes before the cannon went off at half five in the morning. I thought, my God, it's like being alive, finding Nemo down here, the fish were everywhere. I started conjuring my deers for dishes, et cetera, and then I got out of the swim, super relaxed, and then onto the bike because I do relax when I train because I just get into that rhythm and I de-stress and I offload and then I'm uncontactable.
在早上五点半炮声响起前踩水10分钟。我想，天哪，这就像活着，在这里寻找尼莫，鱼到处都是。我开始为菜肴等构思我的鹿，然后我游了出来，超级放松，然后骑上自行车，因为我训练时确实放松，因为我只是进入那种节奏，我减压，我卸载，然后我就无法联系了。
I think that's the most important part about shutting off. No one get hold of me. No one knows that. JB, you have a meditative quality to your workouts too. You like to run for six miles and be kind of non-contactable. I do, yeah. It's just nice, I think just the discipline, right? And it's solitary.
我认为这是关于关闭的最重要的部分。没人能联系到我。没人知道那个。JB，你的锻炼也有冥想的品质。你喜欢跑六英里，并且处于某种无法联系的状态。我确实，是的。我认为这很好，只是纪律，对吧？而且它是孤独的。
It's just you against your body, your will, your discipline. Yeah, I do enjoy it. Hey, Gordon, you mentioned your body, your will, your discipline. Yeah, I do enjoy it. Hey, Gordon, you mentioned your mom a couple of times. She sounds like she was a huge influence on you. Is she still with us? Was she able to see and appreciate your success? Yeah, mom's 78.
这只是你对抗你的身体、你的意志、你的纪律。是的，我确实喜欢它。嘿，戈登，你提到了你的身体、你的意志、你的纪律。是的，我确实喜欢它。嘿，戈登，你提到了你的妈妈几次。她听起来像是一个对你有巨大影响的人。她还在我们身边吗？她能够看到并欣赏你的成功吗？是的，妈妈78岁了。
She's down in Taunton, southwest of England. My first ambition after winning our third mission in style was after selling our house to go and get that lease because the bank wouldn't back us. So that was the only tangible asset I had. After winning our third star, the first time we ever come into any money, I went and bought mum her first house. And so for her to have that in her 50s,
她在英格兰西南部的汤顿。赢得我们第三个任务后的第一个雄心是在卖掉我们的房子后去获得那个租约，因为银行不会支持我们。所以那是我拥有的唯一有形资产。赢得我们的第三颗星后，我们第一次有钱，我去给妈妈买了她的第一套房子。所以让她在50多岁时拥有那个，
something that she's never grown up with, was just one of the most exciting moments of my life. We have so many similarities. Sean, you did the same thing. Yeah, I brought your dad a new set of tires, right? Because he really burned through those first ones getting the hell out of there. Real flat spot on there.
她从小从未拥有过的东西，是我一生中最激动人心的时刻之一。我们有很多相似之处。肖恩，你也做了同样的事情。是的，我给你的爸爸买了一套新轮胎，对吧？因为他确实在逃离那里时烧掉了那些旧的。上面有真正的平点。
Oh, shit. And he ripped the rear views off, too, right? Shit, you guys. Honestly. Oh my God, I'm crying. While the wheel was spinning, he ripped the rear view mirror off, threw it out the window. I think he hit Sean and Tracy both in the forehead with it. Then the tires tracked up and off he went.
哦，该死。而且他还把后视镜也扯掉了，对吧？该死，你们。老实说。哦，天哪，我在哭。当轮子在转动时，他把后视镜扯掉，扔出窗外。我想他用它击中了肖恩和特雷西的前额。然后轮胎跟踪，他就走了。
And we haven't been closer since. My God, honestly. Wait, Gordon, but so many similarities, we don't have to go into it, but my mom, super hard work, workhorse, like I learned everything from her, grew up really poor, five kids, dad was nowhere, and similar, I just have a lot of the same drive that you do, and it's just,
从那以后我们就没那么亲近了。天哪，老实说。等等，戈登，但有太多的相似之处，我们不必深入探讨，但我妈妈，超级努力工作，工作狂，就像我从她那里学到了一切，从小真的很穷，五个孩子，爸爸不在，相似，我只是有和你一样的动力，这只是，
it's great to talk to you about all of that. I get I get it I get where you bought your mama house that would about my mom house so yeah I think yeah it's the best gift you could ever give by the way I've told the story a million I'll tell it later it's it's my mom I did this big moment for her I where I moved her into a condo. This is when you gave her the monocle? Yeah. No. My mom has one eye, Gordon. She had one eye, yeah. And so she, I moved into her condo and while I built her this big mansion for all of us to live in,
和你谈论所有这些真是太好了。我明白，我明白你给妈妈买房子的事，关于我妈妈的房子，所以是的，我想是的，这是你能给出的最好的礼物，顺便说一句，我讲过一百万次这个故事，我稍后会讲，这是我的妈妈，我为她做了这个大时刻，我把她搬进了一个公寓。这是你给她单片眼镜的时候？是的。不。我妈妈有一只眼睛，戈登。她有一只眼睛，是的。所以她，我搬进了她的公寓，当我为我们所有人建造了这座大豪宅时，
and she, and I had that big movie, that bus moment where I filled it, you know, with the furniture and the silver, literally she just had to bring her toothbrush, and she walks in and she was so shocked and so surprised she was crying her eye out. Mmm, mmm, mmm. And she, and she, she's literally touched the couch
而且她，我有了那个大电影，那个公共汽车时刻，我填满了它，你知道，用家具和银器，字面上她只需要带上她的牙刷，她走进去，她太震惊了，太惊讶了，她哭得眼睛都肿了。嗯，嗯，嗯。而且她，她字面上摸了沙发
and she said, I don't know that I would have picked out that couch but everything else is like that and that instead of like, and that, that really. All three of us have the same mom. That's mothers, that's mothers. That's crazy, I remember when she came to Clarities for the first time and she was like the guest of honor for the opening party and they put her upstairs in the penthouse suite
她说，我不知道我会不会选那个沙发，但其他一切都像那样，而不是像，那，那真的。我们三个人有同一个妈妈。那是母亲，那是母亲。太疯狂了，我记得她第一次来Clarities时，她是开幕派对的贵宾，他们把她放在楼上的顶层套房
and the butler came in and said, Mrs. Ramsey, can I run your bath? And she said, certainly not. I can run my own bath. Thank you very much. I'm like, oh my God. Honestly. And then I flew over to LA and we got this beautiful house up in Bel Air Crest
管家进来问，拉姆齐夫人，我可以为您放洗澡水吗？她说，当然不行。我自己可以放洗澡水。非常感谢。我当时想，哦，天哪。老实说。然后我飞到洛杉矶，我们在Bel Air Crest买了这个美丽的房子
and it's beautiful. The views are stunning. It's a dream. And she was looking after the kids while Tan and I went for a run, funny enough. I came back and I said, you OK? She said, yeah, I'm just wandering. You're the neighbors. I said, yeah, what's wrong with them? She said, no one's got their washing out.
它很美。景色令人惊叹。这是一个梦想。当Tan和我去跑步时，她正在照顾孩子，有趣的是。我回来问，你还好吗？她说，是的，我只是在闲逛。你是邻居。我说，是的，他们怎么了？她说，没人把洗好的衣服拿出来。
I said, for fuck's sake, but no one hangs their washing out. Our neighbor for ten years was Stevie Wonder, who lived next door to us. And the sweetest guy, the sweetest guy. And mum didn't even know it was Stevie Wonder. And I'm like, mum, I had to sing her the fucking song. Oh, is that? I'm like, for god's sake.
我说，看在上帝的份上，但没人把洗好的衣服挂出来。我们十年的邻居是史蒂夫·旺达，他住在我们隔壁。最甜的人，最甜的人。妈妈甚至不知道那是史蒂夫·旺达。我当时想，妈妈，我不得不给她唱那个他妈的歌。哦，是吗？我当时想，看在上帝的份上。
I'll pop round and ask if you'd like a cup of tea. She said, no, no, no, mum. You don't pop round to your neighbor's house. You can't do that in LA. Security will take you away. I love that. No, so, by the way, you have a new show coming out which I'll completely watch called Gordon Ramsay's Secret Service.
我会顺道过去问问你想不想喝杯茶。她说，不，不，不，妈妈。你不能随便去邻居家。在洛杉矶你不能那样做。保安会把你带走的。我喜欢这个。对了，顺便说一下，你有个新节目要播了，叫《戈登·拉姆齐的特勤局》，我一定会看的。
Right? When does that come out, by the way? Like May? Yeah, just when does it come out? Maybe it's already out. Secret Service? May 21st. Fuck, sorry, I should know that. Rob's going to kill me. Okay, Maybe it's already out. Secret Service, May 21st, fuck, sorry, I should know that, Rob's gonna kill me. Okay, so it's already out by the time this comes out.
对吧？顺便问一下，那个节目什么时候播？五月吗？对，到底什么时候播？也许已经播出了。《特勤局》？5月21日。该死，抱歉，我应该知道的。罗伯会杀了我的。好吧，也许它已经播出了。《特勤局》，5月21日，该死，抱歉，我应该知道的，罗伯会杀了我的。好吧，等这期节目播出时，它应该已经播出了。
Why do you think, this is one of the dumbest questions, but I can't get enough of food shows, and what is the huge appeal? What is it that taps into people that are, why is everybody obsessed with watching how food gets made? Something we do three times a day, seven days a week, breakfast, lunch, and we eat. I know, but still, why would you want to watch somebody do it?
你觉得为什么——这是一个很蠢的问题，但我对美食节目百看不厌——它的巨大吸引力是什么？是什么触动了人们，为什么每个人都沉迷于观看食物是如何制作的？这是我们每天做三次、每周七天都在做的事情，早餐、午餐，我们都在吃。我知道，但还是那句话，为什么你会想看别人做呢？
I think to make yourself feel better. And everyone wants to be better at it. Exactly that. So I think, you know, there's so much to learn about food. There's so much enjoyment to cooking and it's emotional. And so those emotions, as you know, run high. And Secret Service is everything I've learned over the last 20 years, working in the US, from talented producers to great creators,
我觉得是为了让自己感觉更好。而且每个人都想做得更好。正是如此。所以我认为，你知道，关于食物有很多东西要学。烹饪有很多乐趣，而且它是有情感的。所以正如你所知，这些情绪会很强烈。《特勤局》汇集了我过去20年在美工作期间学到的一切，从才华横溢的制片人到伟大的创作者，
is in this show. Yeah, yeah. I can't wait to see it. It looks so good. Can you guys cook at all? No, I can't even boil water. I can make slappy joes, that's it. But is it a farewell? Is it something that you, is it intimidating? No, it's one of those things every once in a while out of the blue it'll occur to me like, I should learn how to cook,
都在这个节目里。是啊，是啊。我迫不及待想看了。看起来太棒了。你们会做饭吗？不，我连水都不会烧。我只会做邋遢乔三明治，仅此而已。但这是一种告别吗？这是你……这会让人感到畏惧吗？不，这属于那种偶尔会突然闪过我脑海的想法，比如，我应该学学怎么做饭，
and then it goes out of my head and I don't think about it again. And I don't know what it is. No? Sean? No, it's just, it's like, I'm not interested. I'm, you know, I'll get like in the winter, I'll get into baking and I'll bring these guys like over stuff like that I make a lot of the times. And then once I get into the rhythm of like making cheesecakes and cookies and whatever it is,
然后这个念头就从我脑子里消失了，我再也不会去想它。我不知道为什么。不？肖恩？不，只是，我没兴趣。你知道，冬天的时候，我会开始烘焙，我经常会带一些我做的东西给这些人吃。一旦我进入了制作芝士蛋糕、饼干之类的节奏，
I'm like, oh, I kind of see it, but it's the mess and then the cleaning up. And then the- Yeah, that's the thing that keeps me away from it. The ratio between the prep, the cook, the cleanup versus the eating and the enjoyment. It's such a small wedge of, you know, is the eating. I almost don't want to eat it after I make it.
我就觉得，哦，我好像明白了，但麻烦的是清理工作。还有那个——对，那正是让我远离它的原因。准备、烹饪、清理与进食和享受之间的比例。进食所占的比例太小了。我做完之后甚至都不想吃了。
I know, it's just so much time to clean it up and to prep it, I should get into that. And I also love the fact that there's a roadmap, like a recipe book. You can just like, it literally tells you step by step what you need to do to get what looks great and it's going to taste great. And you just, it's dummy proof.
我知道，清理和准备太花时间了，我应该尝试一下。而且我喜欢那种有路线图的感觉，就像食谱书一样。它会一步步告诉你需要做什么，才能做出看起来很棒、吃起来也很棒的东西。这简直是傻瓜式操作。
But the fulfillment is immense, okay? When you get over those bumps and you see that thing on the plate, it's like, wow. But I will say- You can do it with your kids or, yeah. But I will say that the thing I do understand about what you do is when you do make something great and you serve it and somebody says,
但那种成就感是巨大的，好吗？当你克服了那些困难，看到盘子里的成品时，你会觉得，哇。但我得说——你可以和孩子们一起做，或者，是的。但我得说，我理解你所做的事情的一点是，当你做出很棒的东西并端上桌，有人说，
that's the best blank or whatever I've ever had. There is like a ego boost that you're like, oh, I did that. Like that's, you know. It's a great payoff, but you can be taught, okay, all this bullshit about you have to be bought into it. Do you have an educated palate? And you know, do you have to be natural? Absolute bullshit.
这是我吃过最好的某某东西。那种成就感会让你觉得，哦，是我做的。这是一种巨大的回报，但你是可以被教导的，好吗？所有关于你必须对此充满热情的废话。你有受过训练的味蕾吗？你必须有天赋吗？纯属胡扯。
How do I know from a, yes, yes, yes, yes. And so I'm a little bit different to a lot of chefs. I teach my chefs to taste first before we learn to cook from a yes, yes, yes, yes. I'm a little bit different to a lot of chefs. I teach my chefs to taste first before we learn to cook because if you don't understand how it tastes perfectly, you shouldn't be cooking it. and items on the plate, You want me to cook and wash up? Geez. Growing up around mum, there was no such thing as dishwashers back then. You just got in and dug deep and washed up.
我怎么知道……是的，是的，是的，是的。所以我跟很多厨师有点不同。我教我的厨师在学习烹饪之前先学会品尝。因为如果你不了解它完美的味道，你就不应该烹饪它。还有盘子里的食材，你想让我做饭还要洗碗？天哪。在妈妈身边长大时，那时候根本没有洗碗机。你只能亲自上阵，埋头苦干，把碗洗了。
But I am a very smart and tidy worker. I don't make a mess. And so I sort of clean down everywhere I go. A bit of OCD going on. So yeah, the kids are good at cleaning. Alright, a couple of rapid fires here because I know we've got to let you go. You're a car fanatic. What car do you drive? What car do you wish you had? Depends where I am, it depends who I'm with. Majority of the cars we have are all in this incredible hangar that we've just built.
但我是一个非常聪明且整洁的员工。我不会弄得一团糟。所以我走到哪里都会顺手清理。有点强迫症。所以，孩子们打扫卫生很在行。好了，来几个快问快答，因为我知道我得放你走了。你是个汽车狂热分子。你开什么车？你希望拥有什么车？取决于我在哪里，取决于我和谁在一起。我们大部分的车都在我们刚建的那个不可思议的机库里。
Oh my gosh, that's amazing. I'm embarrassed about the collection. I've been collecting for over 20 years. Oh, wow. Don't be. The only way I really get to understand these cars is on the track. So three or four times a year we'll rent a track out. Wow. Truck them down there. I bring in makes. The only way I really get to understand these cars is on the track. So three or four times a year we'll rent a track out, truck them down there, I bring in mates. Silverstone? Silverstone and Thruxton are two big tracks. Thruxton is the biggest track in the UK.
天哪，那太棒了。我对我的收藏感到不好意思。我已经收藏了20多年了。哦，哇。别这样。我真正了解这些车的唯一方式就是在赛道上。所以每年我们会租三次或四次赛道。哇。把车运过去。我带上朋友。我真正了解这些车的唯一方式就是在赛道上。所以每年我们会租三次或四次赛道，把车运过去，我带上朋友。银石赛道？银石和瑟斯顿是两个大赛道。瑟斯顿是英国最大的赛道。
And what's your favorite one to drive? Oh, it's like saying who's the favorite kid. I would say I still love that little Subaru Ghira Aston Martin DB4, or the Ferrari SP3 Monza, an extraordinary piece of kit. How many cars do you think you got? I think it's about 94. So you hate pineapple on pizza, I do too. What is the other shit that you can't... What's another thing that you absolutely cannot stand combined, food-wise? Fucking cold foams, man. When I see foam on a...
你最喜欢开哪一辆？哦，这就像问最喜欢哪个孩子一样。我会说我依然喜欢那辆小斯巴鲁、阿斯顿·马丁DB4，或者法拉利SP3 Monza，那是一件非凡的装备。你觉得你有多少辆车？我想大概有94辆。所以你讨厌披萨上放菠萝，我也讨厌。还有什么东西是你绝对无法忍受的……在食物搭配上，还有什么是你绝对无法忍受的？该死的冷泡沫，伙计。当我看到泡沫在……
What's cold foams? Foam. When chefs start aerating stuff and putting foam on a plate. That's for your fucking chin. Shave with foam. Don't fucking eat it. And that disgusting, sticky, insepid balsamic glaze, I love. I'm with you. I don't like it either. It's too sticky and gross.
什么是冷泡沫？泡沫。当厨师开始给东西充气并把泡沫放在盘子里时。那是给你该死的下巴用的。用泡沫刮胡子吧。别他妈吃它。还有那种恶心、粘稠、平淡的香醋釉，我喜欢。我和你一样。我也不喜欢。它太粘了，很恶心。
I hate that shit. And I think you already answered this, but the one food that you, if you had to live with one dish for the rest of your life, I think it would be a hamburger. Is that correct? It's always going to be a hamburger. It would be a hamburger all day long.
我讨厌那玩意儿。我想你已经回答过这个问题了，但如果你余生只能吃一道菜，我想那会是汉堡包。对吗？那永远会是汉堡包。那会是全天候的汉堡包。
Hamburger. Same. Smashburger. With cheese? No, no, no, X. It'd be a hamburger all day long. Hamburger. Same. Smashburger. Smashburger. With cheese? No, no, no, no, no. Just a beautiful smashburger. Don't deter from the flavor of that beef.
汉堡包。我也是。碎肉汉堡。加芝士吗？不，不，不，X。那会是全天候的汉堡包。汉堡包。我也是。碎肉汉堡。碎肉汉堡。加芝士吗？不，不，不，不，不。只要一个漂亮的碎肉汉堡。不要破坏牛肉的味道。
Lettuce and tomato? No, no, no, no. Just the burger and the bread. And there you go. Are you serious? Nice. Really? Everyone puts lettuce and tomato.
加生菜和番茄吗？不，不，不，不。只要汉堡和面包。就这样。你是认真的吗？不错。真的吗？每个人都会放生菜和番茄。
No, they put lettuce and tomato on there to make you feel fucking better as if it's healthy. Right. Here's your salad. Olive one. We've become accustomed. I like yellow mustard. I've become a big proponent in the last five years of old school plain yellow mustard.
不，他们放生菜和番茄是为了让你感觉好一点，好像它很健康一样。对。这是你的沙拉。橄榄油。我们已经习惯了。我喜欢黄芥末。过去五年我成了老派纯黄芥末的忠实拥护者。
It's the best. It's so good. It's the best. In New York, they don't sell it. You can't find it anywhere. So frustrating. No, because everything is Dijon or some sort of version of there. I know.
那是最好的。太棒了。那是最好的。在纽约，他们不卖这个。你到处都找不到。太令人沮丧了。不，因为所有的都是第戎芥末或者类似的版本。我知道。
It's like spicy whatever. Yeah. Anyways, talk about spicy. Gordon, you're the best. This is wonderful. It's been an absolute joy. It's such an honor to meet you. I've been such a fan for so long.
就像什么辣味之类的。是的。总之，说到辣。戈登，你是最棒的。这太美妙了。这绝对是一种乐趣。见到你真是我的荣幸。我当你的粉丝很久了。
I really have watched every episode and I was just in the UK a couple months ago for a stretch and I found, and I never knew it existed, Kitchen Nightmares, it was Ramsey's Kitchen Nightmares before you came here to do it. And I was like, oh my God, it was a channel that had it on 24-7, I watched every episode of that. I just, I'm just, I love it, I love you, before you came here to do it. I watched every episode of that.
我真的看了每一集，几个月前我在英国待了一段时间，我发现了一个我从未听说过的节目，《厨房噩梦》，那是你来这里做节目之前的《拉姆齐厨房噩梦》。我当时想，天哪，有个频道24小时播放它，我看了每一集。我只是，我只是，我喜欢它，我喜欢你，在你来这里做节目之前。我看了每一集。
I love you, I just love everything you do. It's my one to go to every week when we download. It's an honor to have you. Thanks man, it's so good to see you. Thank you so much. Thanks, guys. Thank you guys. Thanks Sean, thanks Will. Bye-bye. Thank you, Jason. Bye-bye. Bye, buddy.
我爱你，我只是喜欢你做的一切。这是我们每周下载后必看的节目。能请到你是我们的荣幸。谢谢伙计，见到你真好。非常感谢。谢谢你们。谢谢肖恩，谢谢威尔。再见。谢谢你，杰森。再见。再见，伙计。
He barely thanked you at the end there, JB. Did you hear that? Like at the last thing he was like, oh yeah, thanks Jason. Couldn't remember the name. No. It's hard, it's a tough one. So, because he was going to say Justin,
最后他几乎没谢谢你，JB。你听到了吗？最后他说，哦，对了，谢谢杰森。没记住名字。不。这很难，这很难。因为他本来想说贾斯汀，
like everybody else, right? He was going to say, thanks Justin. Right, I got one the other day. It had been a while. I'm so bummed because I'm such a, I really watch everything he does and I was so excited to bring him on and surprise you guys and there's like,
就像其他人一样，对吧？他本来想说，谢谢贾斯汀。对，我前几天也遇到过一次。已经有一段时间了。我很沮丧，因为我是他的超级粉丝，我真的看了他做的一切，我非常兴奋能请他来给你们一个惊喜，结果……
you're like, oh hey Gordon, what's going on? I was like, I didn't know you knew him. We saw, Jason and I saw him recently. Well sorry, we're not like some crazy super cooking show fan, freak. No, I didn't know you knew him. In fact, I've never seen one of his shows but I will now and I do enjoy a cooking in fact I've never seen one of his shows, but I will now, and I do enjoy a cooking show,
你却说，哦嘿戈登，怎么了？我当时想，我不知道你认识他。我们见过，杰森和我最近见过他。好吧，抱歉，我们不是那种疯狂的超级烹饪节目粉丝。不，我不知道你认识他。事实上，我从来没看过他的节目，但我现在会看了，而且我确实喜欢烹饪节目，事实上我从来没看过他的节目，但我现在会看了，而且我确实喜欢烹饪节目，
but I have not seen one. Yeah, no, it's so good. It's so good, it's so good, and he's... Well, I mean, like, who's like, he has so many... I walked through the airport the other day, and I saw this restaurant called Plain Food. P-L-A-N-E. I was like, oh, that's clever, it's Gordon Ramsay.
但我还没看过。是啊，不，它太棒了。太棒了，太棒了，而且他……好吧，我的意思是，谁像他……我前几天走过机场，看到一家叫“Plain Food”的餐厅。P-L-A-N-E。我当时想，哦，真聪明，是戈登·拉姆齐的。
Yeah, there you go. And an airport. And an airport of all places. He's got a restaurant. I mean, he's just. Yeah, he's doing very well. You gotta do well to buy 93 cars, okay? Yeah, yeah.
是的，就是这样。在机场。在机场这种地方。他有一家餐厅。我的意思是，他只是……是的，他做得很好。你得做得很好才能买得起93辆车，好吗？是啊，是啊。
It's insane. 93. Did you say 94? I think he said 94, yeah. Did you say 94? Yeah, I'm pretty sure he said 94. He just bought another one. God, good for him, you know?
太疯狂了。93辆。你说94辆吗？我想他说的是94辆，是的。你说94辆吗？是的，我很确定他说的是94辆。他刚又买了一辆。天哪，对他来说是好事，你知道吗？
I know, I know. Yeah, he's great, I love him. I'd love to go to his, where'd he say it was in Chelsea? Yeah, in Chelsea, let's go, let's go, you know what? Let's go see Shaunie's play. Yeah. And we'll go for dinner there. Let's do that.
我知道，我知道。是的，他很棒，我喜欢他。我很想去他的，他说是在切尔西吗？是的，在切尔西，我们去吧，我们去吧，你知道吗？我们去看肖尼的戏。是的。然后我们在那里吃晚饭。我们就这么做。
And then what about when you're in England doing it? Yeah. No, it's in Chelsea, New York? In London, I think, isn't it? Oh, oh great, okay. Yeah, well, I mean, it's, yeah. Let's do it. Let's do that.
那你在英国做节目的时候呢？是的。不，是在切尔西，纽约？在伦敦，我想，不是吗？哦，哦太好了，好吧。是的，好吧，我的意思是，它是，是的。我们去做吧。我们就这么做。
Bradley's been there. Yeah, okay. How about that? End of story? Yeah, I mean, just like that he's held out on us. We didn't know that, I didn't know that he'd been to this three star, three Michelin star. Right, we'll go to the restaurant. Yeah.
布拉德利去过那里。是的，好吧。怎么样？故事结束了？是的，我的意思是，就这样，他瞒着我们。我们不知道，我不知道他去过这家三星级，米其林三星餐厅。好吧，我们会去那家餐厅。是的。
We'll sit down. I guess we can. We'll have, we'll have. I'm trying to the restaurant. Yeah. We'll sit down. I guess we can. I'm trying to look for one. It's rare that he doesn't build up, so let him build up. I know. I'm like letting him... We'll sit down and we'll just have a nice quick bite. Bite!
我们会坐下来。我想我们可以。我们会吃，我们会吃。我试着去那家餐厅。是的。我们会坐下来。我想我们可以。我试着找一家。他很少不铺垫，所以让他铺垫吧。我知道。我像是在让他……我们会坐下来，吃顿快餐。吃！
Bite! Bite! That was good. Thanks, man. That was really good, yeah. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
吃！吃！那很好。谢谢伙计。那真的很好，是的。SmartLess是由罗伯·阿姆格夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特里手工制作的100%有机艺术品。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。